[Musik]
tag zusammen herzlich willkommen zur zdf
heute live euren ihren live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
und da schaut heute deutschland nach
sachsen anhalt in einer stunde schließen
dort die wahllokale
insgesamt sind 1,8 millionen menschen
dort zur wahl aufgerufen ein neues
landesparlament zu wählen
449 kandidatinnen und kandidaten haben
sich zur wahl gestellt aus 22 parteien
verteilt auf 41 wahlkreise so wird also
die statistiken am ende können natürlich
nicht alle rein kommen wie viel es
werden aus welcher partei
das werden wir im laufe des abends sehen
mit drei von diesen kandidatinnen
kandidaten wollen wir heute abend reden
und zwar mit jungen politiker innen die
sich entschlossen haben sich zur wahl zu
stellen ins landesparlament sich wählen
zu lassen aber noch nicht ganz wissen ob
sie es schaffen werden mit denen fiebern
wir heute abend mit außerdem wollen wir
mit euch einen blick ins zdf wahlstudio
werfen meine kollegin luisa houben ist
für uns in magdeburg und nimmt uns
gleich mal mit und für die politik für
die fragen rund ums geschehen für die
einordnung haben wir auch zwei
ausgewiesene experten in berlin und den
magdeburg zugeschaltet einmal ist das
benjamin höhne politikwissenschaftler
und stellvertretender leiter des
instituts für parlamentarismus forschung
und im zdf-hauptstadtstudio in berlin
ist nicole diekmann für uns zugeschaltet
die schaut sich die wahlergebnisse und
auch die vorberichterstattung machen wir
auch mit ihr aus der bundespolitischen
perspektive an fragen und kommentare
dazu wie immer herzlich gerne in die
dafür vorgesehenen kommentarspalten
meistens hier unter mir oder per e mail
hier ist die matratze eingeblendet zdf
heute - live at zdf.de wird dann hier
sowie ins studio gepusht und ich schaue
wie immer was wir dann mitnehmen können
und weil wir natürlich eine wahl haben
möchte ich euch ganz herzlich bitten
auch wenn er eine präferenz für eine
partei habt hier nicht uns den stream
voll zustimmen mit irgendwelcher
wahlwerbung das müssen wir dann sowieso
löschen werden wir auch tun und da
könnte unseren kommentatorinnen unsere
moderatorinnen moderatorin des kanals
die arbeit sparen auch wenn ich hoffe
dass es technisch bleibt
und außerdem natürlich darauf
geschrieben wenn ihr jetzt stehen teilt
wäre es auch schön damit noch mehr leute
zugucken können
fakt ist in euren instagram stream
facebook twitter wo auch immer ihre
sachen teilen können damit möglichst
viele menschen dabei sein können denn
wir wollen natürlich auch eure fragen
hin mitnehmen eure fragen beantworten
und werden bis ungefähr 20 uhr 30 für
euch hier live sein zwischendurch mal
rüber schalten ins zdf studio wo dann
die aktuelle berichterstattung mit den
aktuellen prognosen mit den
hochrechnungen stattfindet und auch mit
der elefantenrunde wieder so schön heißt
mit den spitzenkandidaten und
spitzenkandidaten aber ab und zu und
zwischendurch foren hinter sind wir hier
für euch da und wir fangen damit an
genau dort in magdeburg wo wir das zdf
wahlstudio aufgebaut haben und hinter
den kulissen oder besser davor ist
glaube ich noch meine kollegin luisa
houben so ist da kannst du mich hören
ja ich werde ich sehr gut
genau wir stehen in der messe in
magdeburg hier hat das zdf das
wahlstudio aufgebaut und wir schleichen
uns jetzt mal da rein
wir dürfen nämlich einmal hinter die
kulissen schauen gerade wird noch
geprüft das heißt bettina schausten
matthias fornoff die sind gerade noch
dabei in den letzten vorbereitungen und
da hinten kann man das sehen
da sind sie gerade dabei noch zu proben
dahinten das sieht man auch gegenüber
von den beiden da sitzt die
forschungsgruppe wahlen also diejenigen
die die umfragen im vorhinein gemacht
haben
ich glaube meine vielleicht sieht man
sich so gut weil da so viele kameras
sind und so viele menschen der
vorstellen aber da sitzen diejenigen die
dann auch gleich für die prognose um 18
uhr verantwortlich sind
und dann können wir uns hier einmal
drehen hier stehen die ganzen pulte wo
die elefantenrunde stattfinden wird von
der du gerade auch schon erzählt haft
die spitzenkandidatin und kandidaten
werden ja hier zu gast sein und dann
hier fleißig diskutieren über das
ergebnis
also ich höre jetzt schon die kommentare
in im stream ohne rhein zu gucken warum
trägst du keine maske luisa was ist da
los also wie finden das ganze unter
coruña statt das ist eine berechtigte
frage aber auf die habe ich auch eine
gute antwort eigentlich also wir haben
wirklich die vergangenen tage immer wenn
wir hier auf die messen wollten auch um
zu proben ist das hier anzuschauen und
überblick zu verschaffen
immer einen test machen müssen für
diejenigen
noch nicht geimpft sind oder oder
vollständig genesen
wenn man dann aber seinen negativen test
vorweisen kann
da musste man auch durch eine
sicherheitskontrolle und dann durfte man
hier rein und das ist wirklich bei jedem
einzelnen jeder einzelnen die heute den
tag verbringt irgendwie arbeitet mit
hilfe der fall und ich tatsächlich ist
auch so nur wenn ich hier in dieser
kulisse wie man es nennt unterwegs bin
darf ich die maske aus haben wenn ich
hier gleich wieder runter gehe um in den
redaktions container zu gehen und
irgendwie mit schluck wasser zu trinken
auf dem weg dahin muss ich meine maske
auch wieder anziehen hier sind auch
menschen die das kontrollieren und ja
jemand uns ermahnen wenn wir uns daran
nicht halten ok also die masken polizei
ist am start das ist doch mal gut zu
wissen ist bei uns übrigens dieser dich
hier rausgehen muss ich auch die maske
wieder aufziehen so kurz nach 18 uhr
gibt es die ersten hochrechnungen wie es
ungefähr ausgesehen hat da gibt es auch
noch ein paar spannende besonderheiten
dienst luisa gleich erklären wird aber
jonas post esch hat für uns erst mal
zusammengefasst was bei der wahl in
sachsen-anhalt eigentlich so auf dem
spiel steht
heute wählt sachsen anhalt einen neuen
landtag
die wahl ist aber auch über das
bundesland hinaus wichtig sie ist der
letzte stimmungstest vor der
bundestagswahl im september
laut zdf politbarometer vom 28 mai ist
für 41 prozent der wähler in
sachsen-anhalt die bundespolitik auch
wichtiger als die landespolitik außerdem
blicken viele gespannt darauf wie stark
die afg hier abschneidet reiner haseloff
von der cdu will nach der wahl weiter
ministerpräsident von sachsen anhalt
bleiben
er selbst ist in umfragen sehr beliebt
ganze 68 prozent der sachsen anhalt ina
wollen haseloff weiter als
regierungschef für seine partei ist der
vorsprung deutlich geringer
zwar ist die cdu stärkste kraft im land
aber die afg bleibt weiter auf einem
starken platz zwei
für haseloff kommt eine zusammenarbeit
mit der rechtspopulistischen parteien
nicht in frage als innenminister holger
stahlknecht im dezember eine cdu
minderheitsregierung vorgeschlagen hat
wurde er von haseloff entlassen
denn die minderheitsregierung wäre auf
stimmen der afg angewiesen gewesen
haseloff wünscht sich eine fortsetzung
seiner kenia koalition aus cdu spd und
grünen
zumindest in den umfragen wäre jedoch
eine sogenannte deutschland koalition
mit der fdp stadt im grünen beliebter
gerade der cdu bundesvorsitzende armin
laschet könnte gute nachrichten aus
sachsen-anhalt gebrauchen
bei den wahlen in baden württemberg und
rheinland pfalz hatte die cdu zuletzt
historisch schlechte ergebnisse
eingefahren und besonders bei den cdu
verbänden im osten deutschlands ist
laschet nicht so beliebt viele dort
hatten sich markus söder als
kanzlerkandidaten gewünscht luisa du
hast für uns das ganze auch beobachtet
den wahlkampf in magdeburg und den
sachsen anhalt ich hatte gerade hier die
frage
die denn so die themen waren ich suche
sie gerade nochmal aber ich glaub ich
finde sie gerade auf anhieb nicht also
was war dein sohn die themen die die
menschen oder vor allem auch die
parteien jetzt bei der wahl um getrieben
haben hier stand auch darauf was im
kommentaren was stand in den auf den
plakaten ein diesel drauf was so
thematisiert wurde
ja also ein ein thema was uns ja immer
alle beschäftigt aktuell ist natürlich
die korona politik und was die einzelnen
parteien tun wollen um ja wie sie mit
der pandemie umgehen wollen das heißt
das war immer ein thema und dann war
aber auch wirklich auch durchweg bei
allen parteien das thema häufig die
gesundheit also was wird getan um eine
gute gesundheitsversorgung hier im land
aufrecht zu erhalten
da gibt es dann die linken die sagen wir
müssen mehr krankenhäuser verstaatlichen
andere sagen wir müssen mehr private
anbieter wie ins land holen die sich
darum kümmern und dann das thema
digitalisierung und das nicht nur im
zusammenhang mit bildung sondern auch
mit infrastruktur in den ländlichen
regionen sachsen anhalt ist ja ein sehr
ländlich geprägtes bundesland und hier
gibts wirklich dörfer und städte wo das
netz echt nicht gut ist also hat man
vielleicht glasfaser aber dann kann
keine mobilen daten oder andere
also als echt noch luft nach oben und
das haben auch alle parteien
thematisiert und wer sehr auffällig war
aber zb die linke die hat den
ost-west-unterschied noch mal groß
plakatiert oder sie habe es nicht
plakatiert aber sie hatten ein plakat
auf dem stand nehmt den wessis das
kommando und sie wollten darauf
aufmerksam machen dass es immer noch
ungleiche lebensverhältnisse gibt in den
westdeutschen und im vergleich zu den
ostdeutschen bundesländern und das hat
dann auch bundesweit für aufsehen
gesorgt und wenn man dann aber zum
beispiel auf die cdu blickt die hat ganz
stark wahlkampf gemacht rund um ihren
ministerpräsidenten den jetzigen reiner
haseloff der war ich auf gut auf jedem
plakat und dann stand da drauf keine
experimente also weiter so wie bisher
ihr kennt mich war die wirtschaft wenn
ihr mich wählt dann wisst ihr was ihr
bekommt das ist aber anspruch der kinder
irgendwo her hört das war irgendwie so
konrad adenauer in den 60ern glaube ich
oder noch davor ich kann mich nicht so
richtig erinnern aber naja da greift man
quasi in die begriffe bin die bewährte
trickkiste bei der cdu
genau das hat merkel hat es ja auch
schon mal gemacht so gefühlt und gesagt
mit mir wissen sie wen sie bekommen und
das ist die linie d die cdu ja auch
verfolgt hat im wahlkampf das war ja
häufig im letzten jahren bei landes tags
wahlkämpfen so ein bisschen das motto
alle gegen die afd
die ist in albaxen anhalt das letzte mal
überraschend stark und sehr schnell
wieder also als erste mal eingestiegen
mit glaube ich 24 prozent war das dieses
mal genauso dass ich das schon im land
er das genauso dieses mal also die afd
war schon im landtag und sie hat letztes
mal dieses extrem hohe ergebnis bekommt
fast ein viertel der stimmen genau und
daraufhin hat dann haben wir die die
anderen parteien gesagt okay wir wollen
die regierung die wir bilden die kinder
koalition wir wollen ein bollwerk gegen
rechts sein also den einfluss der afg so
gering wie möglich halten und dann haben
sie fünf jahre miteinander gerungen aber
diese koalition hat dem ganzen
standgehalten eben auch aus dem grund
und das hat man jetzt im wahlkampf auch
immer wieder gesehen
am anfang haben durch die parteien
versuchen doch
ja so ihre eigenen eigenes profil zu
schärfen
aber natürlich gibt es dann immer die
frage wie geht's weiter nach der wahl
können sie sich vorstellen dass weiter
als die grünen gefragt die spd gefragt
die cdu dass es so weiter geht und das
ist schon der fall weil alle immer sagen
wir wollen eine demokratisch also eine
koalition der demokratischen mitte
bilden das heißt es war häufig das thema
zu sagen bloß keine also los weg von der
afd
eine koalition bilden können am ende es
stehen ja doch sehr unterschiedliche
spitzenkandidatinnen und
spitzenkandidaten zur wahl in sachsen
anhalt matthias kubica hat sich nur die
mühe gemacht und uns die einzelnen der
großen parteien vorgestellt
sachsen anhalt unter kenia schwarz rot
grün auch die politische landschaft ist
einmalig hier
vor fünf jahren war es das einzig
denkbare bündnis um gegen die starke afd
zu regieren
reiner haselhoff will die brandmauer
halten und kämpft energisch dafür dass
die cdu vorne links
wir wissen dass die stimmungslage in
ostdeutschland sehr schnell auch
sozusagen der afg zugute kommt in den
umfragen aber umfragen ist und nicht die
wahlergebnisse die af.de wohl
zweitstärkste kraft setzt auf wut und
protest unter beobachtung des
verfassungsschutzes
wir mussten wir sind mit der
staatssicherheit große warum hat niemand
angst vom verfassungsschutz die linke
wohl erneut schwächer erreicht keine
masse mehr
nehmt den wessis das kommando wollte sie
plakatieren nach schützt uns ließ sie es
lieber sein
sie haben ja die absurde situation dass
in sachsen anhalt im kabinett mehr
menschen mit westdeutscher als mit
ostdeutscher sozialisation zu finden
sind etwas was in jedem anderen
bundesland in den alten bundesländern
völlig undenkbar wäre die spd bank um
zweistelligkeit will trotzdem
weiterregieren
wir haben so viele gute ideen für das
land die kann man nur umsetzen wenn man
auch in regierung dabei ist wenn man
tatsächlich auf die möglichkeit hat die
eigene ideen gesetze zu gießen
die grünen könnten zu gewinnen obwohl es
in der kenya koalition auch ihretwegen
öfter krachte nun finden sie schade dass
das überdeckt dass wir in kenia
inhaltlich für dieses land ganz viel
erreicht haben
zurück in den landtag schafft es
wahrscheinlich die fdp sie würde gern
unter reiner haselhoff mitregieren
tatsächlich scheinen neue ziele möglich
nach fünf jahren kenia geht für sachsen
anhalt die reise nun vielleicht woanders
hin so bevor wir zu den umfragen kommen
seit den letzten ergebnissen der umfrage
nur noch mal kurz ein paar worte zu den
leuten hier im stream
weil es gibt hier einmal eine beschwerde
wir würden cdu kritische kommentare
löschen aber afg kritische kommentare
stehen lassen
also wir kommen nicht immer hinterher
das geht sehr munter ab die gerade bei
euch in den kommentaren
wir werden aber alles was nach
wahlkampfaussagen positionierung so was
wie auch noah afd
lassen wir hier das ist ganz klar dass
die hier auch ist dass viele sachen sind
schon gelöscht und wir können uns da
nicht ein bisschen arbeit ersparen weil
die wahl läuft ja noch deswegen hier
auch die frage von lala bis wie viel uhr
kann man noch wählen gehen oder war es
das schon 18 uhr ist es glaube ich auch
bei euch luisa oder 10 uhr sind die
wahllokale geöffnet
sind also bestimmt noch menschen
unterwegs die gerade ihre stimme abgeben
genau die will man möglichst jetzt nicht
beeinflussen hier aber jetzt kommen wir
zu den umfrageergebnissen wir haben
gerade schon gesehen dass ungefähr
aussieht hat sich da was geändert
teilweise gab es ja auch
umfrageinstitute ideal steht vor der cdu
gesehen haben also wenn man mit den
menschen aus der forschungsgruppe wahlen
spricht habe ich euch ja eben gezeigt
die sitzen da hinten gegenüber von von
den moderationsplan bettina schausten
matthias fornoff dann sagen die sie
sehen eigentlich die cdu immer noch
weiter vorne vor der afd
wie groß der abstand dann am ende sein
wird das verfahren wir dann um 18 uhr
dann sind wir gespannt dann schalten wir
auch live zu euch rüber luisa bis
hierhin erstmal vielen dank wir sind
gleich noch mal bei dir wenn du mit
bedingter chancen muss nochmal durch
studio fürst aber jetzt möchten wir erst
mal ein gespräch führen mit 2 politik
expertinnen einmal nicole diekmann in
berlin zdf korrespondentin und benjamin
höhne politikwissenschaftler und
stellvertretender leiter des instituts
für parlamentarismus forschung in berlin
einen schönen guten abend erste frage
geht an dich nicole diese wahl wird auch
mal wieder aus der bundespolitischen
perspektive mit spannung erwartet wie
wichtig ist sie denn tatsächlich ist
sachsen anderen bundesland wo man sagt
ja das kann auch tatsächlich in der
bundespolitik was bewegen
naja in diesem jahr ist es das auf jeden
fall wir haben es ja eben schon gehört
es ist der letzte und auch erste große
stresstest für armin laschet vor der
bundestagswahl als erster cdu kandidat
und zweitens auch als er als cdu chef
und zweitens als kanzlerkandidat
diese rolle hat er ja nicht ohne regeln
bekommen wir erinnern uns das große
streiten mit markus söder der auch gerne
gewollt hätte der csu chef das heißt
jetzt muss armin laschet zeigen wie
fester im sattel sitzt es gibt im moment
viel viel streit in der cdu es geht um
die ausrichtung wie weit nach rechts
will man oder anders gesagt wie stabil
ist die vielzitierte brandmauer nach
rechts und auch das ist wichtig wenn man
auch diese wahl guckt denn
reiner haseloff sagt ja ganz klar es
gibt keine kooperation nirgends es gibt
parteifreunde von ihm in sachsen-anhalt
bedeutende parteifreunde die sehen das
nicht so eng und es wird heute auch
darauf ankommen wie stark haseloff als
ministerpräsident aus dieser wahl hinaus
geht und das strahlt natürlich auch aus
berlin aber auf die bundespolitik klar
herr höhne woran liegt denn das dass man
eigentlich ein landesparlament wählt und
die bundespolitik schaut trotzdem darauf
eigentlich ist das doch ein bisschen
unfair oder wir sind nicht einmal mehr
in der politik
deutschland ist eine mär ebene
demokratie das heißt es gibt mir relativ
starke föderale ebene ist die
bundesebene
und insofern das sagte jetzt auch in
gewisser weise ein stimmungstest für die
bundesebene
wobei wir aber auch gesehen haben bei
den jüngsten landtagswahlen das doch
sehr differenziert gewählt worden ist
das heißt dass bei allen landtagswahlen
landespolitische themen die personen des
landes im vordergrund standen
und man sich nur sozusagen nach berlin
gespielt hat und davon seien seinen
seine wahl abhängig gemacht hat
inwiefern unterscheidet sich denn jetzt
die politische landschaft in sachsen
anhalt von der in anderen bundesländern
herr höhne
heute ist ein besonderes bundesland ist
ein ostdeutsches bundesland das heißt
dort ist die situation für die
großparteien die partei mit
volksparteien anspruch eine andere sie
sind dort durch die reihe schwächer
aufgestellt als in den westlichen
bundesländern
und man hat das mit einer stärkeren afd
zu tun die auch viel weiter nach rechts
außen weist bündnis 90 die grünen und
die fdp tun sich traditionell im osten
schwer wobei insbesondere die bündnis 90
die grünen durch den aufwärtstrend im
bund aber auch mit einem deutlichen plus
rechnen können jetzt in sachsen-anhalt
vielleicht nicht ganz so stark wie für
die fdp aber da zahlt sich sicherlich
auch der kurs von linde auf der
bundesebene für sie positiv aus nicole
tour begleitet ja die afg schon lange
als korrespondent in und schaust da ganz
genau hin
jetzt wird der landesverband sachsen
anhalt ja seit einigen wochen vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet was ist da
die genaue begründung
genau naja verfassungsschützer halten
sich gerne eher bedeckt was ihre arbeit
angeht aber es ist ganz klar ein name
der immer wieder fällt das ist hans
thomas schneider der in der
landesverband gewählt worden ist der
sachsen anhalt tisch leider war man muss
sagen war ein führendes mitglied des
sogenannten flügels in der afg der ja
formal aufgelöst ist und vom
bundesverfassungsschutz als
rechtsextremistisch gesichert
rechtsextremistisch eingestuften worden
ist es gibt eine besonderheit t
schneider wurde gleichzeitig zusammen
mit jan hoet der kopf des sogenannten
flügels und andreas kalbitz auch der
kopf des flügels der mittlerweile aus
der rfg haus geschmissen worden ist weil
er der afg zu extremistisch war diese
drei kalbitz körper und tisch leider
werden als personen zusätzlich vom
bundesverfassungsschutz beobachtet das
heißt wenn jemand wie till schneider in
den vorstand eines landesverbandes
gewählt wird dann sagt das eine menge
über diesen verfassungsschutz aus ich
fahre ja seit jahren zu den parteitagen
der afd
dort meldet sich tisch schneider
regelmäßig zu wort und fällt dort durch
radikale äußerungen auf rund hat
außerdem enge kontakte zu identitäten
bewegung
jetzt gibt es aber aus der afg aber die
begründung das ganze wer politisch
motiviert es gibt auch aussagen hier bei
uns im zdf von bundespolitikern die
sagen meine partei ist nicht
extremistisch was heißt denn das genau
politisch motiviert politisch motiviert
das ist natürlich der versuch von
führenden fd funktionärinnen die noch
ein interesse daran haben dass die
partei nach außen hin gemäßigt auftritt
und eben nicht insgesamt beobachtet wird
vom bundesverfassungsschutz sich den
naja nach außen hin zu präsentieren als
eben nicht so radikal und mit der
begründung naja durch die absetzung von
hans-georg maßen als
bundesverfassungsschutz präsident sei
also und durch seinen nachfolger thomas
heyden bank seid also quasi der
bundesverfassungsschutz in der hand der
sogenannten
parteien damit meint man die im
bundestag vertretenen anderen
demokratischen parteien
das wird also als ein komplott
hingestellt von der afg also vorteil der
afg muss man sagen es gibt auch genügend
die sagen ist uns egal ob er vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet werden oder
nicht und die meinen dass auch
tatsächlich so aber diejenigen die damit
ein problem haben und angst für
mitglieder und wähler in und schwund die
versuchen also die geschichte zu
verbreiten das narrativ zu etablieren
dass dahinter die verzweiflung steckt
der parteien die sich gegen eine immer
weiter erstarken der afg anders nicht
mehr zu wehren wissen erhöhen jetzt aber
die afg tatsächlich sehr stark also die
umfragen sind eindeutig das geht
richtung gute 20 prozent plus
wenn jetzt alle parteien auch die cdu
die ja auch konservativ ist nur
zusammenarbeit ausschließt muss man da
nicht auch sagen da wird ein teil der
wähler einfach unter werden einfach
ignoriert
ich würde schon sagen es ist wichtig das
wahlverhalten der wählerinnen ernst zu
nehmen die die fdp gewählt haben und
auch nach den gründen zu fragen auch als
auftrag für alle parteien sich mit dem
hohen mit den hohen prozent werden für
die after auseinanderzusetzen
und das betrifft eben nicht nur die cdu
sondern das betrifft auch die spd bis
hin zur linkspartei
wenn wir uns die wählerwanderung
bilanzen anschauen also da gibt es
gründe
und da haben glaube ich alle parteien
auch ein stück weit etwas aufzuholen
das interessante ist aber das ist heute
man schon gesagt hat die afd im osten ja
deutlich nach rechts weist und sie
trotzdem weiter gewählt wird das heißt
eben da kein großer abschreckungseffekt
davon ausgeht dass die vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird anders
im westen
dort befürchtet man auch dass eine
beobachtung der gesamtpartei negative
effekte für ihr wahlverhalten hätte aber
im osten ist das eben nicht so was
meines erachtens nach dafür spricht dass
sowohl protestpotenzial weiterhin
gebunden wird rechtsextremes weder
spektrum gebunden wird und sich
populistische einstellungen verfestigen
da habe ich ihn ganz interessanter
kommentare dazu zum beispiel von sascha
johnny schröder auf facebook der meint
dass wir den wollte ich nicht vorlesen
ich wollte den von mn auf youtube
vorlesen genau der bezieht sich darauf
die linke ist in mitteldeutschland
wegbereiterin der afd
jahrelang hat man ressentiments gegen
die da oben und die wessis geschürt von
dieser stimmung können die
rechtspopulisten jetzt profitieren und
kanzler krüger auf youtube meint auch
ich bin erstaunt wie viele menschen aus
frustration parteien wählen ohne sich
über die konsequenzen gedanken zu machen
ist da was dran dass die linke da auch
ich sag mal ein stück verantwortung mit
dafür trägt wenn wir die frage an sie
erinnern ja eine partie auf die versucht
ja diesen status den die linkspartei
auch innehatte als regionalpartei als
ostdeutsche interessenvertretung spa
drei streitig zu machen
das gelingt ihr ein stück weit die linke
hat versucht dem auch etwas
entgegenzusetzen und in der tat ich
meine gibt es genug punkte glaube ich
für ostdeutsche über die man sprechen
muss
wo es vielleicht gewisse repräsentations
defizite im bundesdeutschen
parteiensystem zu beobachten gibt und
damit ist die linke bisher ganz gut
gefahren diese offen zu kommunizieren
sich da auch ein stück weit als
sprachrohr zu verstehen und das versucht
eben nun die afc aber zusagen bei der
linkspartei das nicht mehr so gut
gelingt und die afg auch versucht diese
richtung einzuschlagen funktioniert am
ende nicht weil es ja tatsächlich auch
was da ist was sozusagen ostdeutsche
typisch aus deutsche belange sind die
artikuliert werden wollen dann danke ich
ihnen soweit herr höhne für diese
einschätzungen sie müssen jetzt weiter
sie sind halt ein vielgefragter mann die
call diekmann bleibt uns zum glück
erhalten den rest des abends immer
wieder für fachgespräche und alissa jung
hat sich für uns mal angeguckt wie der
wahltag bis jetzt in sachsen-anhalt
gelaufen ist
weiter so oder aber alles auf neu
darüber können 1,8 millionen menschen in
sachsen anhalt nun entscheiden wenn man
irgendwas ändern will dann muss man
wählen gehen bin enttäuscht gemachte zu
sorgen wurde nicht anja ein jetzt nicht
mal annähernd so vielleicht können wir
einfach der korona kram aufhören und
dann wäre alles gut möchte man gar nicht
dass die pandemie sein land womöglich
weiter gespalten hat ist auch dem
ministerpräsidenten bewusst jede rolle
ist wichtig aber gerade in zeiten wie
jetzt wo wir uns nach wie vor in
schwierigen situationen befinden
pandemie und ähnliches mit einer
gewissen zerrissen heute auch in der
gesellschaft das letzte zdf
politbarometer sieht die cdu zwar vorn
doch dicht gefolgt von der afg mit
spitzenkandidat oliver kirchner eine
koalition mit afd
oder aber der linken schließt haseloff
klar aus denkbar sind also nur bündnisse
mit der spd den liberalen sofern sie es
wieder in den landtag schaffen oder den
grünen deren spitzenkandidatin wie viele
wahlberechtigte ihre stimme per brief
abgegeben hat die vorläufige
wahlbeteiligung um 14 uhr war in diesem
jahr etwas niedriger als bei der letzten
wahl
allerdings sind da die briefwähler noch
nicht berücksichtigt die dieses jahr
viel stärker zu buche schlagen werden
am ende ist dann die große frage wer mit
wem
ja die werden wir wahrscheinlich heute
abend so eindeutig nicht beantwortet
bekommen aber zumindest eine tendenz
könnte es geben
nicole ich habe jetzt hier mehrere
themen ich fange mal an mit einem
kommentar von sascha den ich gerade
nicht vorlesen wollte jetzt die sich in
vor ich hatte das gefühl dass
landesthemen weniger wichtig waren die
bundesthemen erhöhung des mindestlohns
ost west rentenangleichung amazon
besteuern alles themen die auf plakaten
standen aber auf dem land gar nichts
entschieden werden das würde ja wiederum
heißen im endeffekt wird dann doch
wieder wahlkampf mit bundesthemen
gemacht oder
ich glaube das ist in diesem jahr
sowieso stärker der fall als sonst weil
corona damit hat reiner haselhoff ja
auch schon mal prophylaktisch im vorfeld
versucht
sich ein bisschen abzusichern gegen
mögliche stimmenverluste und auch
nochmal auf den bund geschimpft auf die
bundes notbremse die an mehrere wochen
lang gegriffen hat also klar gerade in
so einem jahr einem super war ja ja mit
blick auf september sind natürlich
bundespolitische themen von belang
sowohl aus sicht der wähler innen als
auch aus sicht der parteien klar
jetzt habe ich hier zwei fragen die
gehen in eine ähnliche richtung und zwar
wird immer angenommen
die afg würde die meisten stimmen heute
bekommen super lemgo und uwe trautmann
wollen in etwa wissen was würde denn
passieren wenn die afb gewinnen würde
und dann eventuell keinen
koalitionspartner findet ja dann wird's
bunt also man muss immer noch mal dazu
sagen klar muss das diskutiert werden
das ist ja theoretisch möglich dass die
afg stärkste kraft wird aber in den
allermeisten umfragen lag die cdu vorne
es ist eben dieser dieser besondere
moment so funktionieren wir menschen ja
dass die afg stärkste kraft werden
könnte
der hat verfangen in unser aller
bewusstsein und deswegen wird darüber
jetzt viel diskutiert klar ist aber die
afg wird ein starkes ergebnis holen wird
allerhöchste wahrscheinlichkeit nach das
zweithöchste ergebnis holen
es will niemand mit ihr koalieren das
bedeutet das je nach stimmverteilung
mehrere mögliche koalition jetzt schon
diskutiert werden entweder eine
fortsetzung der kenya koalition die es
ja im moment eben gibt das sieht im
moment am wahrscheinlichsten aus oder
eine deutschland koalition das bedeutet
also cdu zusammen mit fdp und spd oder
auch simbabwe
das wäre dann cdu spd grüne und fdp ja
also das in bunte farben spieler da
sagen politikwissenschaftlerin und immer
okay kann man natürlich aus demokratie
theoretischer sicht komplett
nachvollziehen ja also diese brandmauer
ist aber insofern problematisch als dann
der gemeinsame nenner natürlich immer
kleiner wird also es sind die
kompromisse die in solchen
koalition eingegangen werden müssen
werden dann immer größer jetzt habe ich
in frage die haben wir schon mal ein
bisschen angesprochen dann geht es um
die cdu und um armin laschet aber noch
mal tatsächlich ein bisschen tiefer
nachgehakt von tobias mandelartz auf
facebook der schreibt es wird immer
wieder kolportiert dass dies auch eine
schicksalswahl für laschet sein wird der
standard die cdu schlecht ab könnte man
das ihm auch anlasten dass söder team
lauert ja schon fast auf ein schlechtes
abschneiden und damit für eine
eventuelle zweite chance
wie realistisch sind solche
gedankenspiele und wir müssen wir
überlegen die bundestagswahl ist nicht
mehr lang hin also ist es tatsächlich
denkbar dass armin laschet nach einer
schlecht schlechten abschneiden seiner
partei in sachsen-anhalt sagt okay ich
mache das doch nicht also wir haben ja
jetzt so viel in den letzten monaten
gesehen was vorher undenkbar war dieser
offen ausgetragene streit diese
hängepartie bis dann der kanzlerkandidat
stand zwischen cdu und csu
beziehungsweise auch innerhalb der cdu
dabei da steht ja auch nicht
unangefochten oder unumstritten aber es
ist relativ unwahrscheinlich es sind
jetzt noch nicht mal mehr vier monate
bis zur wahl
markus söders werte in der in bayern
haben ganz schön gelitten
er hat ja nicht aufgehört zu sticheln
nachdem armin laschet fest stand als
kanzlerkandidat als gemeinsamer kandidat
von cdu csu
da ist ja auch stratege der wird wissen
es ist vielleicht keine so tolle idee
dann jetzt weiter am stuhl zu sägen auch
wenn die wahl heute für reiner haseloff
für die cdu für armin laschet nicht so
ausgeht wie sie das eventuell sollte und
die die konservativen wähler innen
schätzen keinen streit wenn der jetzt
wieder los pflicht dann zeigt die ganze
union darauf ein also daran kann
eigentlich niemand interesse haben ok
also wir halten das er für nicht denkbar
aber tatsächlich haben wir dieses jahr
gelernt man darf niemals nie sagen
nicole bis hierhin vielen dank wir
sprechen später weiter jetzt schalten
wir aber nochmal nach magdeburg in
unserer zdf wahlstudio wo luisa houben
unsere ja ich sag mal zeremonien
meisterin des abends wird die chancen
bei sich hat
ganz genau wir sind immer noch im
wahlstudio und bettina schausten es bei
mir sie ist gerade in den letzten
vorbereitungen für die sendung deswegen
nur ganz kurz die frage welche
erwartungen haben sie an den abend heute
also man merkt jetzt schon so eine
viertelstunde vor beginn unserer
wahlsendung ist kribl doch alle sind
jetzt gespannt wie wird das ausgehen um
18 uhr
und ich bin vor allem gespannt wie wird
das an der spitze aussehen also man hat
ja zwischendurch im wahlkampf gehört das
könnte möglicherweise ein kopf an kopf
rennen stattfinden
die letzten umfragen der
forschungsgruppe wahlen hat schon einen
deutlichen vorsprung für die cdu gesehen
kommt es so ist der vorsprung
komfortabel das wird interessant sein
und was sind dann die auswirkungen
natürlich für die anderen parteien genau
und meine frage zielt genau darauf ab
denn die war deshalb besonders so
interessant weil sie die letzte
landtagswahl vor der bundestagswahl ist
weil was denken sie welches signal wird
von dieser landtagswahl ausgehen in
richtung bund in richtung ja auch
bundestagswahlkampf für alle anderen
parteien also es sieht schon stark
danach aus dass die cdu hier ein
positives signal bekommt in für die
bundestagswahl
von daher wird herr haseloff
wahrscheinlich amila schild heute auch
eine freude machen jedenfalls wenn es so
kommt wie die vor umfragen sagen denn
laschet daran gab es ja zweifel auch von
haseloff selbst ob er eine gewisse zu
kraft entfalten kann
wahrscheinlich ist es nicht sein sieg
hier aber er wird ja es wird ihm nutzen
das ist eines klar er kann das mitnehmen
als rückenwind wer da sonst noch
rückenwind bekommt ich glaube die
anderen parteien haben dann eher ein
interesse dass man schön liegen zu
lassen und es in sachsen anhalt zu
lassen also wir schauen vor allen dingen
auf die cdu jetzt ist ja auch immer die
afg besonders spannend sie glauben also
nicht dass es tatsächlich so sein könnte
dass die afd
die cdu überholt das ist ja das was doch
besonders diskutiert wurde jetzt im
vorhinein genau wie ich vorhin sagte die
letzten umfragen eigentlich schon der
vorvergangenen woche der
forschungsgruppe wahlen haben die cdu
schon vorne gesehen die umfragen sind ja
in der regel sehr gut und von daher
glaube ich nicht so richtig an ein kopf
an kopf rennen
gleichwohl kann die afg mit hohen
ergebnissen rechnen und auch da muss man
fragen warum ist das so ist das eine
besonderheit sachsen an
ich glaube es wird sich zeigen dass die
fdp eben gerade in ostdeutschland
weiterhin stark sein kann und und auch
hier möglicherweise wieder wird und
darauf müssen natürlich auch die anderen
parteien antworten finden vielen dank
eine gute sendung könnten will und damit
gebe ich werfe spielt hat wir gehen
zurück zu dir
daniel und sind dann sehr gespannt was
es hier die erste prognose sagt da hab
gleich einig wie du vielleicht
beantworten kannst vielleicht auch nicht
wir gucken einfach mal den die tabletten
wollte auf youtube wissen wie es mit der
wahlbeteiligung ausgeht kann es sein
dass das wahlkreise gibt in denen nur
die meisten prozent wählen gehen ich
hätte meine frage noch dran corona macht
auch mit dieser wahl was stichwort
briefwählerinnen wie sieht es damit aus
also ich war eben bei der
landeswahlleiterin und die hat gesagt um
14 uhr lag die wahlbeteiligung bei 27,1
das war weniger als bei der landtagswahl
2016 aber ziert auch gesagt die
briefwahl anteil der ist da nicht mit
eingerechnet
und die forschungsgruppe wahlen die geht
auch davon aus dass der briefwahl anteil
größer sein wird als vor fünf jahren
sie schätzt ihn so auf 16 prozent also
das ist auch nicht so viel wie
vielleicht in den anderen bundesländern
die wir bei den anderen wahlen jetzt die
wir schon erlebt haben im frühjahr aber
da gibt es auf jeden fall eine tendenz
dazu dass mehr menschen per brief gewalt
gewählt haben dieses mal da sind wir
gespannt welche auswirkungen das
vielleicht haben könnte auch auf die
prognosen luisa wir sehen uns später
noch mal bis hierhin erstmal vielen dank
und ich hatte ja schon eingangs gesagt
es stehen jede menge kandidatinnen und
kandidaten zur wahl 449 sind insgesamt
22 parteien sind dort vertreten auf
insgesamt 41 wahlkreise verteilt und bei
einigen ist klar dass sie in das
parlament kommen das ist relativ fix
entweder weil sie den wahlkreis schon
sehr lange und sehr fest in ihrer hand
haben oder weil sie bei den
listenplätzen ganz oben stehen andere
hingegen sind neu sind neulinge stehen
in der rangliste etwas weiter unten und
ja gucken heute mit spannung auf das
wahlergebnis für ihre partei mit drei
davon wollen wir jetzt reden einmal mit
an für schulz von bündnis 90 die grünen
mit
tessmann von der cdu und mit constantin
pot von der fdp und wir fangen an in
halle bei antje schulz die ist gebürtige
mecklenburg vorpommern wohnt jetzt aber
dort in sachsen-anhalt 31 und juristin
und hier ist ihr kurzer steckbrief antje
schulz 30 jahre alt vorsitzende der
grünen im stadtverband halle die
juristin promoviert zurzeit an der uni
halle ihre schwerpunkte in wissenschaft
und politik tierschutzrecht und
demokratie bei der wahl heute tritt sie
als direktkandidatin in halle an und
steht auf platz 11 der landesliste und
ich begrüße frau schulz bei mir hallo
guten abend die erste frage die ich
jetzt allen dreien stellen möchte die
sich hier gleich mit uns unterhalten ist
ganz einfach warum frau tools weil ich
die notwendigkeit gesehen habe ich wurde
angefragt vor einiger zeit auch richtig
lust habe auch die liste zu kommen und
dann hab ich gefragt gibt es gibt es
anderes personal haben wir nicht leute
die schon länger vielleicht dabei sind
und dann hieß es aber wir finden es gut
wenn du dabei bist und dann dachte ich
mir ja dann mache ich das dann setze ich
mich mit auf die liste keine angst vor
bearbeitung oder sorge vor so viel
verantwortung das ist ja dann doch ein
kaltstart wenn man irgendwie da mit
anfang 30 in so ein landesparlament
gewählt werden würde oder
ja natürlich also wer nicht zu lange
drüber nachdenke kommt mir natürlich
auch der kalk der kalte schweiß vor der
ganzen verantwortung regeln zu machen
die nicht nur für mich was bewirken
sondern die für das ganze land
sachsen-anhalt gültig sind und damit
auch das leben von sehr sehr vielen
menschen beeinflussen hoffentlich zum
positiven das ist zumindest mein
anspruch aber insgesamt denke ich wir
müssen einfach an und vor allem auch die
jungen damit halt einfach die stimmen
nicht verloren gehen
jetzt habe ich mal geguckt was so ihre
themen sind sie sagen klimakrise
gefährdende demokratie artensterben das
sind sie ihre herzen systemen das sind
alles ein bisschen düstere prognosen
warum denn so negativ
na ja also ich meine wir können uns
jetzt die dinge schön reden in der welt
oder wir können doch einfach mal auf die
tatsachen gucken und die tatsachen sind
halt wir haben eine mittlerweile leider
etablierte afd
das ist eine gefahr für die demokratie
dagegen müssen wir angehen
wir können so tun als wir können jetzt
nur auf die ich sage mal demokratischen
parteien schauen und die afg ausblenden
aber es bringt uns nicht weiter
genau das gleiche mit der klimakrise wir
können so tun als würde das die art wie
witten wirtschaften uns wohlstand
bringen und nicht auch den rest nicht
auf die restliche welt gucken aber das
wäre auch wieder für möglichkeit
verweigerung
das ist nicht meine art und deswegen die
probleme einfach benennen sie einmal
scharf angucken und dann versuchen zu
ändern
wie reagieren denn die menschen die sie
im wahlkampf herz getroffen haben der
ein bisschen anders ablief als sonst
denke ich mal aber wie reagieren die auf
diese themen sind das themen wo sie das
gefühl hatten
okay da packe ich auch die menschen die
auf dem land in sachsen anhalt leben
tatsächlich da wo sie wo es ihnen brennt
unter den nägeln brennt
das ist ja doch für die grünen manchmal
in ländlichen gebieten eher schwierig
oder das mag so sein
nichtsdestotrotz wir haben uns dieses
mal in unserem wahlprogramm auch ganz
klar wieder für die stärkung des
ländlichen raums ausgesprochen wie wir
das auch in den fünf jahren
regierungszeit immer wieder zum thema
gemacht haben
1 und unsere hauptthemen in diesem
wahlkampf und für die nächsten fünf
jahre arbeit im parlament wird seine
mobilitäts wende herbeizuführen und
sachsen anhalt beide verkehrswende zu
unterstützen und das gilt natürlich auch
vor allem im ländlichen raum um neue
mobilitätskonzepte anzubieten um die
menschen eine perspektive zu geben
jenseits des autos das heißt das konkret
also auto ist ja doch für viele menschen
so der einzige weg überhaupt von a nach
b zu kommen wenn man irgendwie in dem
300 seelen dorf wohnt und da mal zum
arzt muss genau und das klagen wir eben
gerade an also zum einen wollen wir
natürlich das gesundheitssystem im
ländlichen raum stärken mit innovativen
konzepten und zum anderen aber auch die
mobilität so abändern dass ein auto
nicht mehr nicht mehr zur pflicht wird
wenn man auch stimmen also wenn man sich
entscheidet auf dem land zu wohnen
und dazu gehört dann zum beispiel in
sachsen anhalt takt also eine
mindestanzahl an wussten die stündlich
oder alle zwei stunden durch die dörfer
durchfahren und dadurch halt ein netz
entsteht um leute von a nach b zu
bringen und zwar zuverlässig jenseits
jenseits von kalkulation ob sich das
auch lohnt in diesem dorf den bus
anhalten zu lassen
jetzt warten sie darauf ob sie es
schaffen in den landtag einzuziehen wie
gut den dann ihre chancen mal hand aufs
herz
je nachdem welcher umfrage man glauben
schenken mag ich persönlich würde mich
wahnsinnig freuen den einzug zu schaffen
es jetzt direkt zu schaffen
während auch die fdp vielleicht einzieht
würde aber vielleicht ungefähr 12
prozent für die grünen erfordern
das haben die umfragen fast nicht
hergegeben vor allem die in den letzten
tagen und wochen nichtsdestotrotz das
hoffen bleibt aber selbst wenn ich nicht
mit ins parlament komme dann das ist
jetzt irgendwie auch nur zweitrangig
hauptsache ist wir grünen haben eine
deutliche stärkung und können deshalb
auch in den nächsten fünf jahren in
sachsen anhalt einfach unsere themen
voranbringen würden sie dann das nächste
mal wieder kandidieren wenn es jetzt
dieses mal nicht klappt oder würden sie
daten okay nur einmal hat es nicht
funktioniert dann mache ich was anderes
also egal wie die wahl heute ausgeht ich
werde auf jeden fall weiterhin ganz
aktiv bei den grünen mitgestalten wollen
in welcher position das sein wird kann
ich jetzt noch nicht sagen und vor allem
kann ich auch nicht sagen wie mein leben
in fünf jahren aussehen wird und welche
welche notwendigkeit ich bis dahin sehr
irgendwo arbeit zu ergreifen
wo schauen sie denn jetzt heute sich das
wahlergebnis anders sieht gerade nach
einem passenden im streaming studio aus
wo sind sie denn da gerade wir hatten
wir hatten das glück bei freunden
unterkommen zu können die technisch ganz
gut ausgestattet
sind unser stadtvorstand und unsere
direkt kandidierenden sind heute hier
privat untergekommen ganz in der nähe
vom marktplatz und alle unsere
mitglieder aus halle werden dann digital
dazu geschaltet sodass wir uns alle
ergebnisse gemeinsam anschauen können
und gemeinsam beraten können ok dann
sind wir gespannt frau schulz wie das
ausgeht wir werden nach den
wahlergebnissen ungefähr gegen 19.30
jeder zu ihnen schalten und da mal sehen
ob sie es geschafft haben oder nicht wir
sind auf jeden fall gespannt und bis
dahin wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und wir schalten weiter zu unserem
nächsten gesprächs gab der hass sich für
ein leben auf dem land entschieden
zum testen heißt er ist 31 jahre alt
verwaltungsfachangestellter und in der
cdu und hier ist sein kurzer steckbrief
im test mann 31 jahre alt
landtagskandidat der cdu
der gelernte sozialpädagoge und
verwaltungsfachangestellte studiert
aktuell digitalisierung und
sozialstruktur wandel seit 2009 10 sitzt
er im sozialausschuss des stadtrats von
haldensleben
dort tritt er als direktkandidat an sein
listenplatz 25
und da ist im test man bei uns einen
schönen abend
ich habe gerade schon die frage nach
halle gestellt an ihre ja politische
konkurrenz und stellte sie auch sie an
sie die geistig frage ist relativ
einfach warum hätte er ist man ja also
ich fand so weil ich bin stadt gehört
hat mich jetzt einmal eingebracht und
vorher war ich in einem handballverein
tätig und da auch mal tätig und hat sich
das alles so ergeben und wir letztes
jahr angesprochen ob ich mich den so
nominierung auf der nächte und habe mich
durchgesetzt in zwei andere können
werden das heißt es ist tatsächlich so
dass man angesprochen wird von von
verantwortlichen ob man jetzt lust hat
sich da mal in die bütt zu begeben wie
man in köln sagt oder dringend zu
steigen
das macht man nicht von alleine also ich
wollte tatsächlich angesprochen von beim
stadtverband ob ich mir das vorstellen
könnte
und wie lange haben sie überlegt ja da
meine freundin war und ich da zu dem
zeitpunkt ein kind erwartet haben haben
wir drei tage drüber geschlafen sage ich
mal habe ich auch zugesagt
das ist ja auch schon einen job glaube
ich der mehr als 40 stunden in der woche
in anspruch nimmt das heißt dass da
bereiten sie sich auch schon sehr darauf
vor dass sie dann vielleicht mal öfter
wechseln von der jungen familie
ja genau also die strukturen oder wie
der tagesablauf wäre das müsste man sich
ja noch alles zurecht legen
ich denke mit einem vernünftigen
zeitmanagement ist dass alles machbar
natürlich auch mit genügend einsatz für
dieses kanzleramt oder dieses
abgeordneten an wenn es denn so kommen
sollte er jetzt habe ich bei ihnen auch
mal geschaut wo für sie so interessieren
und sie machen einen berufsbegleitenden
master digitalisierung und struck sozial
strukturwandel
da muss man ja mal sagen wenn man zum
beispiel auf die breitbandentwicklung in
sachsen-anhalt guckt da war die cdu in
letzten jahren nicht ganz so erfolgreich
also ich habe mal so ein bisschen
recherchiert glasfaser gibt es bei ihnen
dem bundesland nur stellenweise nur 50
prozent der haushalte haben auch
schnelles internet mit mindestens 50
mbit was es auch nicht so doll
woran liegt's ja gut also das kann man
jetzt nicht verheimlichen dass der
schleppend natürlich alles angelaufen
ist ich muss sagen ich persönlich habe
hier jetzt eine viel höhere
breitbandanbindung und bin sehr
zufrieden gerade in unserem neuen haus
hier und ich weiß dass auch viel in
diesem bereich getan wird auch von den
kommunen und gehen wir uns im landkreis
ich denke das sollte man jetzt nicht
pauschalisieren auch das ganze land
sachsen anhalt
bei uns geht es jetzt ja eigentlich
schon relativ schnell vorwärts und ja
ich denke in meiner gemeinde ist es in
den nächsten zwei jahren abgeschlossen
ist das tatsächlich noch eine sache der
kommune oder kann die könnte da die
landesregierung auch mehr machen
nein natürlich können anreize geschaffen
werden durch fördermittel
das ist natürlich logisch ja
aber natürlich auch der bund der da
schon viel geld investiert hat
aber ich denke es ist ein zusammenspiel
aus allen das ist immer für mich ganz
wichtig dass man dann vernünftig
kommuniziert zwischen einen instanzen
die wir so haben im föderalismus und ich
denke dass man da mehr an einem strang
ziehen muss und dann auch schneller zu
schnellerem internet kommt und jetzt
habe ich sie nachgesehen sozial
strukturwandel ist ihr master können sie
das mal ein bisschen konkretisieren was
was heißt das womit beschäftigt man sich
da ja genau also das ist schon so
ausgelegt dass man natürlich den
ländlichen raum sage ich jetzt mal
lösung findet gerade hier für uns in
denen in den ostdeutschen bundesländern
wie wir mit den rückgängen der der
einwohnerzahl umgehen wie wir mit
unseren dörfern gemeinden umgehen und
diese zukunftsfähig zu gestalten da
spielt die digitalisierung eine große
rolle
da kann man viel machen in zukunft ist
ein sehr spannendes thema und gehört bei
uns im land sachsen-anhalt natürlich der
strukturwandel durch die durch den
braunkohle ausstieg eine sehr großes
thema wo vier förderverein gehen in den
nächsten jahren und somit möchte ich das
ganz gerne aktiv begleiten und habe auch
mit diesem studiengang besucht gibt's da
immer so ein herzensprojekt wo sie sagen
okay wenn ich in den landtag komme dann
möchte ich mich in dieser arbeitsgruppe
stürzen oder möchte mich besonders damit
beschäftigen natürlich aus meiner
provisionen heraus ist natürlich die die
soziale arbeit etwas soziales natürlich
die landesentwicklung das wäre jetzt
noch so was für mich sport
landwirtschaft habe ich sehr lieben
gelernt jetzt während des wahlkampfes
muss ich ehrlich sagen wir haben
herausragende landwirtschaftliche
produkte bei mir irgend wahlkreis und
diese diese kräfte zu bündeln und
überregional bekannt zu machen das würde
mir sehr wichtig sein so jetzt habe ich
hier tatsächlich sehr viele fdp wähler
in den kommentaren und wählerinnen wo
ich noch mal sagen kann also jegliche in
parteinahme für oder gegen eine partei
werden wir hier einfach rigoros löschen
das könnt ihr euch eigentlich sparen uns
und euch die arbeit aber das ist
natürlich ein thema mit dem sich die cdu
in sachsen-anhalt sehr dezidiert
auseinandersetzen muss
sie haben viele wähler an die fdp
verloren was meinen sie woran liegt das
und ich hab' ich habe schon mal gesagt
wir als cdu müssen uns mit uns selbst
beschäftigen wir müssen uns fragen was
haben wir vielleicht nicht ganz richtig
gemacht was haben wir wo war hatten wir
schwächen wo waren wir ein bisschen zu
vorsichtig welche nischen konnten wir
nicht mehr berlin
mir ist es immer sehr wichtig dass wir
viel bürgernähe haben dass wir in den
wahlkreisen unterwegs sind und das ist
vielleicht in den letzten jahren ein
bisschen verloren gegangen
aus der betrachtung eines bürgers nicht
aus der betrachtung ist cdu
parteimitglied und dafür möchte ich aber
aufstehen sind eine neue junge cdu die
sich sehr engagiert vor ort welche rolle
spielt die bundeskanzlerin und auch die
bundespolitik
gerade jetzt im ländlichen ostdeutschen
raum dass man da sagt ok von denen fühle
ich mich nicht mehr vertreten
ja gut also während des wahlkampfs haben
hier ist natürlich gemerkt dass das ging
los mit der mit der kubakrise bayern vor
eingang der wahlkampf startete die
stimmung war schlecht
sie wurde ein wenig besser zum ende hin
aber die bundespolitik von natürlich
immer wieder thema und ja und das wird
oft auch leider nicht unterschieden ob
wir jetzt zu einer landtagswahl antreten
oder zu einer bundestagswahl die die
menschen vor ort nicht antworten auf
ihre fragen das haben wir natürlich
versucht zu geben aber wir müssen immer
noch darauf hinweisen dass wir im
landtagswahlkampf nicht im
bundestagswahlkampf der jetzt ja dann
hat montag war sie beginnt ob sie da
reinkommen in den landtag in
sachsen-anhalt werden wir in nicht ganz
so langer zeit wissen wo gucken sie denn
jetzt sie sind zu hause habe ich gerade
verstanden genau also ich bin ganz ganz
ruhig zu hause mit familie eltern und
wir machen den gerät vielleicht noch ein
bisschen an und lassen ihn ein bisschen
ausklingen und gucken was jetzt gekommen
und dann wird entweder angestoßen auf
das eine oder das andere gehe ich mal
davon aus dass man vielen dank wir
sprechen uns dann später weiter und sind
gespannt ob sie es geschafft haben oder
nicht
und als nächstes schalten wir nach
magdeburg dort ist konstantin pott uns
zugeschaltet er ist 23 in der fdp und
hier ist ein kurzer steckbrief
constantin pott 23 jahre alt
spitzenkandidat der jungen liberalen in
sachsen-anhalt pott studiert politik und
wirtschaftswissenschaften seine
politischen themen bildung jugend
digitalisierung
er ist der jüngste direktkandidat in
halle seine partei wählte ihn auf platz
7 der landesliste
einen schönen guten abend herr pott so
ich sehe sie sind draußen unterwegs
ich habe ihren mitbewerberinnen gerade
schon immer die gleiche frage gestellt
und stelle ich auch ihnen warum
naja ich glaube es ist ganz wichtig dass
wir mehr junge menschen in der politik
haben denn wir den einfach schnitt uns
im landtag anschauen empfiehlt es dort
an vielen menschen und das war eine ganz
entscheidende motivation für mich zu
sagen auch ich kandidiere zur
spitzenkandidatur der jungen liebe rein
und dann eben auch für die fdp und
einfach zu schauen dass wir dieses
bundesland für junge menschen besser
machen für junge menschen attraktiver
machen und dass die eben mitgestalten
können die am ende die zukunft in diesem
bundesland auch noch erleben sie sind ja
mit 23 noch wirklich relativ jungen
führen kandidaten sie sind stellen
mitarbeiter im wahlkreisbüro von frank
witter das ist der landesvorsitzende der
fdp sachsen anhalt wie es anders
gelaufen wenn sie das gleich mdl werden
dann würden sie sofort ja eine
blitzkarriere hinlegen oder und ihr chef
müsse sich in anderen mitarbeiter suchen
na gut fragt sich da hört natürlich auf
und wird nicht noch mal für den
bundestag kandidieren aber natürlich
ging das dann alles recht schnell auch
vom eintritt in die partei dann
vielleicht in den landtag aber soweit
ist es noch nicht wir müssen erstmal die
ergebnisse gleich abwarten die auf den
zahlen abwarten und bis dahin bin ich
aber erst bei optimistisch dass es
dennoch klappt wie es denn dass wenn man
auf einmal dann in dieser
verantwortlichen position wäre haben sie
da nicht auch ein bisschen bammel weil
das wäre dann der wirklich so quasi auch
vom hörsaal in den plenarsaal
also ich würde es eher respekt man hat
natürlich respekt vor der aufgabe und
vor allem weil die mandat war es ein die
wählerinnen und wähler gegeben haben
aber man geht natürlich
mit viel motivation und viel frische
blind glauben daran und ich würde mich
sehr freuen wenn nicht diese aufgabe
dann am ende auch angehen kann
ich habe auch bei ihnen geschaut was sie
ihre themen sind daher finde ich auf
ihrer homepage bildung jugend
digitalisierung warum ausgerechnet diese
drei
naja bildung ist glaube ich einfach das
zukunftsthema für uns junge menschen um
chancengerechtigkeit wirklich auch
gewährleisten zu können und dafür zu
sorgen dass den menschen hier bleiben
und in dieses bundesland kommen damit
den universitäten und hochschulen da
sehr guten ansatz da müssen wir auf
jeden fall noch weiter machen das ist
einmal deswegen das thema bildung jugend
ich bin junger mensch ich möchte mich
für die jungen menschen einsetzen ich
bin in diesem bundesland aufgewachsen
und ich weiß warum junge menschen eben
auch das bundesland verlassen und
vielleicht nicht hier bleiben und weil
sie das ansetzen
warum tun sie das das hat ganz
unterschiedliche gründe
ich glaube ein grund ist perspektive
weiterer grund ist dass manche leute
sich einfach hier vielleicht doch nicht
so wohlfühlen
es ist ein ganz unterschiedliche gründe
wirtschaft und so weiter ich glaube da
müssen wir an mehreren stellschrauben
drehen damit wir als bundesland einfach
attraktiver werden und das dritte thema
digitalisierung es gibt auch das
zukunftsthema mit um den ländlichen raum
vor allem attraktiv zu machen wir haben
immer weniger junge menschen im
ländlichen raum dann müssen wir dann
eben auch schauen dass wir die digitale
infrastruktur schaffen und dass du da
einfach mal dran gehen
was ist damit klimaschutz das ist ein
thema wo man immer wieder hört dass es
vor allem das was junge leute umtreibt
weil es ja eben um den erhalt unseres
lebensraumes geht das steht bei ihnen
nicht ist ihm doch nicht so wichtig doch
natürlich ist es wichtig aber ich
überlasse das thema dann eher den
anderen experten in unserer partei und
ich glaube als juli spitzenkandidat
sollte ich mich auch vor allem auch die
jüngeren themen sind für mich diese drei
konzentrieren wir haben im bereich
umweltschutz und umwelt andere leute die
wissen doch deutlich besser bescheid und
deswegen glaube ich ist es besser wenn
diese leute dann auch diese themen
spielen die fdp könnte jetzt ganz gut
abschneiden bei der kommenden wahl zum
arbeiter gerade noch laufenden weil wir
haben noch fünf minuten tatsächlich dann
sind die wahllokale
geschlossen wie groß sind denn jetzt
ihre chancen realistischerweise ja gut
also listenplatz sieben es gibt keinen
sicheren listenplatz aber es ist eben
auch nicht unmöglich wir werden am ende
auch sehen natürlich viele direktmandate
an welche parteien gehen da kann
natürlich auch sich immer noch mal ein
bisschen was verschieben und
ausgleichsmandaten
ich schätze meine chancen sehr gut an
und ich bin sehr optimistisch dass auch
wenn es vielleicht längerer abend wird
es am ende reicht das heißt wo gucken
sie jetzt wo sind sie da gerade ich bin
bei der wahlparty der fdp sachsen anhalt
wo viele kandidaten sind auch unsere
spitzenkandidatin wieder des pins und da
bin ich bin ich heute da kommen wir
gleich die fragen sind wie viele
menschen hinter allen haupt also es ist
alles bewohner konform sind alle
getesteten oder genießen
ich glaube die aktuelle verordnung lässt
wenn es professionell organisiert sind
auch 50 leute in sachsen anhalt zu da
wäre eigentlich eine sehr gute
entwicklung bei den uns die grenzen zu
verzeichnen haben dann hoffen wir dass
das gut geht und wir werden auch mit
ihnen später noch mal sprechen wenn wir
die wahlergebnisse haben zumindest die
vorläufigen prognosen
vielen dank für ihre zeit herr pott und
ich schalte jetzt noch mal ganz kurz
bevor wir ins zdf wahlstudio schalten zu
meiner kollegin nicole diekmann
nicole ich habe mir noch so ein paar
fragen von denen ich mir hoffe dass du
sie vielleicht klären kannst also wann
sieht man die ergebnisse war kann das
jemand beantworten also das kann noch
ein bisschen dauern
ja das kommt drauf an also es ist ja
relativ relativ hohe
briefwahlbeteiligung aber wir haben
schon bis nach mitternacht wahlabend der
erlebt bis dann das amtliche endergebnis
feststand das hängt von so vielen
faktoren ab das kann niemand vorhersagen
dann eine frage die wir ja so ebenso ein
bisschen angesprochen haben was passiert
wenn die afg gewinnt und das keinen
koalitionspartner gibt es nach seiner
aussieht sind betrag man wissen wenn ich
es richtig verstanden habe heißt das
dass die afg ruhig gewinnen kann aber
politisch hätte sie keinen einfluss das
im endeffekt selbst wenn sie gewinnt
würde sie auf jeden fall in die
opposition gehen und da kann auch
niemand was dran ändern
so sieht's aus da sind die aussagen der
anderen parteien sehr klar ist gibt eine
gemeinsame brandmauer das bedeutet das
habe ich ja eben schon gesagt dass es
viele mögliche sehr bunte ungewöhnliche
koalitionen gibt bis hin zu müssen waffe
aus cdu spd grünen und fdp das muss man
abwarten aber dass jemand mit der afg
koaliert das ist nicht vorgesehen
nicole dann vielen dank du bleibst uns
auch noch die nächsten stunden erhalten
wir sind gespannt auf das vorläufige
ergebnis aber auf die hochrechnungen und
wir sprechen uns später wieder eine
frage möchte ich noch beantworten die
uns gestellt wurde hier unter anderem
von richard anderer ob sie auch jemand
von der afg eingeladen haben oder warum
nicht von allen parteien kandidaten
eingeladen wurden wir haben uns bemüht
wir haben von der fdp sächlich niemanden
bekommen der oder die zeit hatte oder
lust hatte und von der spd haben wir
auch niemand eingeladen wir wollten
tatsächlich das ganze spektrum abbilden
sondern einfach dreimal begleiten
bei der frage ob sie heute abend
reinkommen so es ist jetzt 1758 das
heißt in zwei minuten können wir mit den
ersten hochrechnungen rechnen und
deswegen schalten wir jetzt rüber zu den
kollegen ins zdf wahlstudio nach
magdeburg
umfragen sind inzwischen anders sehen
einen vorsprung also gibt es noch sorge
vor einem schlechten ergebnis
also bettina sorge ist hier eigentlich
nicht zu spuren er vor freude oder die
hoffnung darauf dass man hier heute
abend was feiern kann
hier ist eine location am stadtrand von
magdeburg zwischen impfzentrum und
dinosaurier ausstellung und alle die
hier sind und es sind tatsächlich einige
gekommen konzentrieren sich auf einen
wie auch schon im wahlkampf auf
ministerpräsident reiner haseloff
eigentlich sollte der jetzt im cabrio
sitzen david hasselhoff hören und mit
seiner frau den ruhestand genießen
aber er hat gesagt in diesem schwierigen
zeiten nicht nur wegen corona muss ich
noch mal weitermachen
insofern hofft man hier dass man drei
sachen feiern kann dass
ministerpräsident haseloff
ministerpräsident bleibt dass man
stärkste kraft wird und dass man sich
den koalitionspartner aussuchen kann
dankeschön christina in einer halben
minute die prognose professor karte wie
wichtig ist auch für armin laschet heute
ein erfolg in sachsen-anhalt extrem eine
so gebeutelte cdu braucht den siegte
klaren deutlich selbstbewusster sieg von
haseloff damit könnte er richtig aus ihr
dann schauen wir jetzt mal denn all das
wird jetzt beantwortet in der 18 uhr
prognose der forschungsgruppe wahlen die
wir in genau jetzt 55 sekunden sehen
43 21 man darf nie sofort sein für die
u35 deutliche gewinne afd 23,5
geringfügige verluste linke 11 deutliche
verluste spd acht verluste das ist ein
negativrekord im land grüne 6 ganz
leichte gewinne fdp 7
das sind gewinne und damit wäre sie
jetzt wieder im landtag freie wähler 3
prozent geringfügig verbessert die
anderen zusammen bei 6,5 also großer
abstand für die eu zur afd
was das jetzt bedeutet für die
sitzverteilung für koalitionen das alles
jetzt von matthias fornoff ja welchen
das schauen wir uns jetzt sofort haben
mit einer kurzen erklärung vorweg im
magdeburger landtag wird es mindestens
83 sitze geben
aber die cdu wird mehr direktmandate
gewinnt als ihr nach den zweitstimmen
zustehen würden
deshalb bekommt die sogenannte
überhangmandate das wird ausgeglichen
mit ausgleichsmandaten für die anderen
parteien so dass das kräfteverhältnis
sich nicht verändert und wer erstmal mit
den 83 rechnen können also die absolute
mehrheit die liegt bei 42 die cdu kommt
auf 32 sitze die afg auf 22 die linke
auf 10 spd 7 grüne 6 und fdp ebenfalls
sechs was heißt dass fürs regieren in
magdeburg welche koalition hätten da
eine mehrheit die liegt bei der zahl die
welt annehmen bei 42 sitzen das wäre die
absolute mehrheit die kenia koalition
die derzeit amtiert kommt auf 45 ist
also relativ klar drüber
die sogenannte deutschland koalition wo
die fdp anstelle der grünen mitregiert
kommt ebenfalls auf 45 sitze und eine
koalition aus cdu grünen und fdp also
jamaika auf 44 auch das würde reichen
die wahlbeteiligung übrigens liegt ja
ziemlich genau so wie vor fünf jahren
bei rund 61 prozent
dankeschön matthias also wir sehen
reiner haseloff wird die wahl haben er
kann weiter machen hat platz eins
erobert und das mit einem sehr
deutlichen abstand vor der afg deshalb
wollen wir jetzt gleich mal schauen wie
dieses
prognose ergebnis aufgenommen worden ist
bei der cdu christina ja also hier war
der jubel groß muss man sagen wie tina
als die zahlen gerade kamen 35 prozent
das ist weit mehr heraus gesagt haben
das ist gar nicht so weit entfernt von
den 39 prozent die cdu in sachsen-anhalt
mal als bestes ergebnis hatte 1990 da
war das und damit kann man jetzt
natürlich heute abend feiern und man
kann sich auch überlegen mit wem man
denn diese regierung jetzt bilden möchte
wenn man sich hier um hört dann hört man
zwar auch wertschätzung für die kinder
koalition und auch für die arbeit der
grünen aber die tendenz geht schon stark
in richtung deutschland koalition und
die liebe zur fdp die ist hier natürlich
unverkennbar traditionell zu hören
1 noch die frau von reiner haseloff ist
zahnärztin und reiner haseloff sagt ich
habe deshalb noch so viel biss weil ich
patient bei meiner eigenen frau bin
jetzt muss er zeigen dass er die
nächsten fünf jahre diesen biss noch
weiter behalten kann und damit zurück zu
euch ins studio bettina dankeschön
christina ja und in berlin können wir
jetzt bereits die ersten reaktionen
einfangen von der cdu zum beispiel ich
bin verbunden mit dem
cdu-generalsekretär zehn jahre genannt
guten abschluss schossen
ja also reiner haseloff hat das rennen
noch mal gemacht und zwar sehr deutlich
und das vermutlich doch wohl auch dank
seines enormen amtsbonus den wir hier
vorhin schon gezeigt haben wie sehen sie
das ist dies vor allem ein persönlicher
sieg für ihn
es ist ein persönlicher sieg vor reiner
haseloff aber des ganzen teams der cdu
in sachsen-anhalt wir haben auch als cdu
deutschlands gemeinsam mit den freunden
von gekämpft insofern ein starker
kandidat ein klares profil der mitte und
geschlossenheit das war ausschlaggebend
sachsen anhalt bleibt stabil und die cdu
hat diese wahl deutlich gewonnen heute
ist ein guter tag selbst war es ja der
sich im zurückliegenden unions
machtkampf um die kanzlerkandidatur wenn
wir uns da mal kurz rein erinnerung
erinnern eigentlich markus söder
gewünscht hatte stadt armin laschet weil
weil er in laschet eher eine belastung
sogar für den wahlkampf in sachsen
zwar sehen sie das jetzt widerlegt
reiner haseloff in armin laschet haben
gemeinsam wahlkampf gemacht sie haben
gemeinsam geworben bei den wählerinnen
und wählern und diese geschlossenheit
diese gemeinsamkeit auch der wahlkampf
von armin laschet hat sich ausgezahlt
dass es übrigens der größte zuwachs den
wir bei einer landtagswahl haben seit
dem wahlsieg der cdu in
nordrhein-westfalen 2017
insofern geschlossenheit unklares profil
gerade im bereich des strukturwandels
das war den menschen sehr sehr wichtig
in sachsen-anhalt da ist reiner haseloff
eine starke stimme auch für den sozialen
ausgleich genauso wie armin laschet und
sie nehmen jetzt den wind aus
sachsen-anhalt natürlich gerne mit in
den bundestagswahlkampf ziehen sie noch
moment bei uns ich will aber auch gerne
begrüßen ihren kollegen von der spd
denken generalsekretär lars klingbeil
der uns ebenfalls zugeschaltet ist
schönen guten abend erklingen bald das
abschneiden ihrer partei kann ihnen
jetzt nun keine freude machen
sie hatten vermutlich sich auch
rückenwind natürlich gewünscht aus
magdeburg der kommt aber nicht jetzt hat
sie ihr kanzlerkandidat olaf scholz
besonders schwer oder also in der tat
das ist kein schönes ergebnis wir hatten
uns deutlich mehr erhofft in
sachsen-anhalt wir haben gekämpft wir
haben zusammen gekämpft katja pele hat
die spd neu aufgestellt in sachsen
anhalt ein junges team die haben
engagierten zuversichtlichen wahlkampf
geführt und ich hatte mir in der tat der
hofft dass da dass da mehr drin ist
heute abend
man muss sagen herr haseloff hat gerade
in den letzten wochen noch wirklich
zugelegt dazu gratuliere ich ihm auch er
hat eine polarisierung als person ja zur
haft die hinbekommen und es gab viele
menschen in sachsen anhalt die gerade
bei diesem kopf an kopf rennen zwischen
haseloff und der harfe was die letzten
tage ja sichtbar war da haben viele dann
gesagt dann wählen wir jetzt ein
haseloff weil wir nicht wollen dass die
fdp in sachsen anhalt stärkste kraft
wird
so erkläre ich mir diesen deutlichen
wahlsieg und dazu gratuliere ich
herzlich
ja da war eine polarisierung eindeutig
gleichwohl haben sie jetzt noch mal ein
problem es sind gut drei monate bis zur
bundestagswahl und die spd sich jetzt
hier ein in die riege der kleinen
parteien wie groß ist ihre sorge dass
das ab herbst in berlin
dann auch so sein könnte hätte es war
eine landtagswahl wenn ich auf die
letzten landtagswahl beispielsweise in
rheinland-pfalz gucke da die spd ganz
andere ergebnisse gehabt also es hat
hier wirklich das hat ihm ja gerade
große herausforderungen vor ort gegeben
es hat gerade die polarisierung mit der
hfg gegeben das ist eine wahl die jetzt
nicht zu sagen hat für das was 112 tagen
ist die bundestagswahl
also da kämpfen wir da sind wir
geschlossen da gibt es viele
möglichkeiten auch noch über themen zu
reden und wir haben mit olaf scholz das
zeigen die aktuellen befragung wir haben
den kanzlerkandidaten denen die menschen
sich am besten im kanzleramt vorstellen
können und jetzt gilt es diese
persönlich guten werte von olaf scholz
auf die spd zu übertragen
eine frage noch mal zurück zu vollziehen
jagt dem cdu-generalsekretär das ist ein
großer erfolg für die cdu für reiner
haseloff gleichwohl muss man natürlich
sehen dass die afg kaum verloren hat
sondern tatsächlich sehr stark bleibt
warum ist das offenkundig nicht gelungen
der der ard mehr stimmen abzujagen das
ist tatsächlich auf kosten der anderen
gegangen
ja es ist tatsächlich ein sensationell
gutes ergebnis und im vergleich zu den
umfragen die es gab haben wir wirklich
unglaublich viel aufgeholt und deswegen
ist meine frage auch an die anderen
parteien
das ist ja nicht nur eine frage der cdu
wie das ergebnis der a- fds ich glaube
wir haben hier ein klares profil haben
viele wählerinnen und wähler wieder
zurückgewonnen und hatten dann übrigens
doch mit angriffen auch der spd und
grünen gegen reiner haseloff zu kämpfen
in diesem wahlkampf das hat sich nicht
ausgezahlt die menschen haben gesehen
die cdu steht für einen vernünftigen
kurs der mitte für sozialen ausgleich
und hat einen starken
ministerpräsidenten und genauso werden
wir es auch im bundestagswahlkampf
handhaben mit armin laschet an der
spitze und einer geschlossenen cdu
dankeschön an paul berg und an lars
klingbeil die beiden generalsekretäre
von cdu und spd bis nach berlin so und
jetzt schauen wir mal hier zur afd
in unserer prognose bei 23,5 leicht
unter dem ergebnis von 2006 sendung wie
das aufgenommen wurde
schipanski es bei der alv
hier in magdeburg
ihr spitzenkandidat ist derzeit nicht
aber alexander daum spricht und wie sie
hören wird auch kräftig gejubelt
entscheidend war aber punkt 18 uhr als
das ergebnis der cdu zunächst verkündet
wurde
da war hier doch ein kleiner moment der
schockstarre und des eisigen schweigens
damit hatte man offenkundig nicht
gerechnet dass die union so abschneiden
könnte als dann das ergebnis der afg
verzeichnet wurde
da war dann alles hier zu hören es ist
schon klar dass man hier auf den nenner
ist zu sagen wir haben ungefähr das
ergebnis gehalten vom letzten mal man
ist auch klar dass in der aussage dass
man sagt die derzeitige regierung hat
keine gute arbeit hier geleistet aber
die macht doch zu unserem trainerstab
die scheint jetzt doch wirklich
unwahrscheinlicher geworden zu sein
und das schmeckte durchaus erste stimme
ja denn von der stärkste kraft ist man
natürlich in der tat weit entfernt
darüber werden wir später auch reden
können mit dem bundessprecher kuba ab
den wir hier im studio noch erwarten
jetzt schauen wir mal wiederum weiter zu
den grünen die sich sicherlich auch mehr
erwartet hatten in berlin bin ich
verbunden mit deren
fraktionsvorsitzenden im bundestag
katrin göring eckardt schönen guten
abend
so nun ist sachsen anhalts alles andere
als eine hochburg für sie aber hätte das
grüne signal nicht doch deutlich
kräftiger ausfallen müssen jedenfalls
wenn man in gut drei monaten das
kanzleramt erobern will
natürlich hätten wir uns mehr erhofft
das ist jetzt ein ordentliches ergebnis
ein ordentlicher zuwachs das muss man ja
auch sagen das scheint so zu sein dass
wir über dem ergebnis der letzten jahr
auch schon sehr schwierigen landtagswahl
liegen
man muss aber auch sagen sachsen anhalt
und der osten das ist was ganz anderes
als der bund hier kämpfen wir
tatsächlich um das kanzlerinnen abend
hier könnten wir tatsächlich dafür dass
die frage des klimaschutzes zum leitbild
für die künftige politik wird und das
was das team bei gerade bei ihnen gesagt
hat stimmt sicherlich auch dass viele
menschen mit einer klaren haltung in
sachsen-anhalt verhindern wollten dass
die afd tatsächlich einfluss auf die
politik hat und die haben sich dann wie
beispielsweise in brandenburg
beispielsweise in sachsen oder in
thüringen dafür entschieden reiner
haselhoff zu unterstützen
aber wie weit steht jetzt sachsen anhalt
auch für den für aus deutschland
insgesamt hier kamen auch ihre
kanzlerkandidatin annalena baerbock
nicht besonders gut an die menschen
halten klimaschutz das thema hier für
nicht so bedeutend
das sind keine guten perspektiven auch
für die bundestagswahl oder ich glaube
tatsächlich die klimakrise wirkt sich
auch in ostdeutschland aus da gibt es
erstmal keinen unterschied und die frage
ist welche konzepte haben wir dafür
eigentlich wir werden natürlich nur das
tun können was notwendig ist was das
bundesverfassungsgericht uns aufgegeben
hat insgesamt in der politik nämlich
vorangehen mit dem klimaschutz dazu
gehört aber auch soziale ausgleich
das zeigt sich übrigens auch am ergebnis
der spd wenn populismus dem klimaschutz
helfen würde dann hätte die spd zulegen
müssen wir sagen nein klare maßnahmen
und eine klare soziale ausgleich mit dem
energie geld das wir vorschlagen was vor
allen dingen denen hilft die wenig geld
im portemonnaie haben aber grüne erfolge
die sind vor allem westdeutsche
grüne erfolge sind auch ostdeutsch das
kann man daran sehen dass wir ja in
mehreren ostdeutschen ländern
mitregieren und dort auch zeigen was
geht und wie es geht und gerade in
sachsen anhalt in dieser wirklich
schwierigen koalition in den letzten
jahren haben wir gezeigt dass stabilität
das haltung aber eben auch klimaschutz
ganz zentral sind für eine gute für eine
stabile regierung und das wird sich dann
ja auch für die zukunft zeigen was da
notwendig ist was da wie notwendig ist
aber ich sage nochmal natürlich ist es
kein einfaches pflaster und die
wählerinnen und wähler haben sehr
deutlich gemacht sie möchte nicht dass
die rechtsradikalen einfluss auf die
politik in diesem bundesland haben
vielen dank frau göring-eckardt zur
vollständigkeit muss man auch sagen dass
das natürlich noch nicht ausgemacht ist
dass die grünen weiter mitregieren in
sachsen anhalt das werden dann
koalitionsverhandlungen zeigen vielen
dank nach berlin
und wir können noch mal ein bisschen
analyse dazu liefern matthias fornoff
denn wir haben da interessante
ergebnisse aus den forum fragen über die
grünen so sieht's aus bettina wir
schauen uns das hier mal an die
bewertung der regierungsarbeit vor allen
dingen auf der skala von plus fünf bis
minus fünf wird die cdu mit 1,7 plus
bewertet dass sein guter wert die spd
mäßig mit plus 0,9 und die grünen mit
minus 0,7 das ist ein extrem schlechter
wert sie ist also mehr oder weniger
untergegangenen der wahrnehmung in
dieser position der regierung
wir nehmen die nächste grafiken gucken
mal auf die kompetenzverteilung im
bereich klimapolitik cdu 19 prozent afd
acht linke 4 spd sechs und die grünen 30
prozent also man sieht schon hier in
sachsen anhalt wo die kernkompetenz der
grünen liegt aber und das ist das
problem das zeigen wir mit der nächsten
grafik in sachsen anhalt gibt es viel
wichtigere themen als den klimawandel
dieser aussage stimmen 75 prozent also
drei viertel der befragten in sachsen
anhalt zu und dann ist es eben auch klar
dass eine partei mit dieser
kernkompetenz ist hier schwer hat und
eine art auswärtsspiel dankeschön
matthias interessante werte zu der afg
und ein neuer gast hier bei uns im
studio nämlich die motoballer der
bundesvorsitzende der afc einer von
beiden und auch einer von zwei
spitzenkandidaten der afg für die
bundestagswahl
sowas haben wir in der prognose 23 5 das
sind geringfügige verluste es wird sie
aber freuen dass sie stark bleiben und
die afg hier in sachsen anhalt durchaus
auch eine hochburg hat gleichwohl ihr
wahlziel stärkste kraft zu werden ist
verfehlt und das wert deutlich woran
also wir haben uns von vornherein
vorgenommen über 20 prozent zu kommen
wir sind deutlich über 20% sie haben
richtig gesagt wir haben unser ergebnis
gehalten das stimmt uns sehr zufrieden
es gibt mittlerweile in sachsen anhalt
nur noch zwei volksparteien das ist die
cdu und das ist die afd
wir haben bei vielen kernthemen sozialen
themen bildungspolitik haben gepunktet
haben wieder wähler aus der mittel- und
aus der arbeiterschicht dazugewonnen und
das macht uns ja optimistisch und ich da
bin ich sehr stolz auf meine partei und
in dem zusammenhang möchten wir auch bei
unseren ganzen wahlkämpfen und
kandidaten bedanken wenn sie sagen es
gibt zwei große kräfte dann haben sich
die wählerinnen und wähler hier
gleichwohl sehr deutlich für die cdu
entschieden also von einem kopf an kopf
rennen waren sie ja in der tat weit
entfernt woran lag das ist es am ende
doch so dass der sachsen-anhalter
landesverband dann doch zu radikale töne
von sich gibt
denn ich denke eher dass der wähler hier
stark konservativ bürgerlich gewählt hat
dass der wählerwille ist ja klar
erkennbar wenn die cdu mit über 30
prozent die afg mit 24 23 prozent die
abschneidet dann haben wir eine
schnittmenge von über 50 prozent ist
klar bürgerlich konservativ gegenüber
den anderen parteien die sich ja
mittlerweile alle um die zehn prozent
herum tummeln
also das zeigt doch eigentlich ganz klar
was die was die bürger in sachsen anhalt
wollen eine regierung aus cdu fdp wähler
haben bürgerlich gewählt nämlich mit 35
prozent die cdu das ist ein relativ
klares ergebnis gewesen und ich will
noch mal nachfragen
sie kennen ja die stimmen aus diesem
landesverband in sachsen anhalter wurden
corona maßnahmen inklusive impfung als
unterdrückungsmaßnahmen tituliert ist
wurde vor einer angeblichen corona
diktatur gewarnt es gab den aufruf
verschwörungstheorien zu verbreiten all
das gehört ja hier zum repertoire ihrer
kolleginnen und kollegen in sachsen
anhalt sie haben da keinen grund sich zu
distanzieren
auch nicht nach dem ergebnis ich besser
gewünscht hätten also erstmal muss man
sagen wir sind hier als
oppositionspartei angetreten wir haben
hier klar opposition betrieben und als
opposition wollen wir natürlich auch
andere themen im vordergrund bringen und
haben auch andere meinungen und wollen
natürlich auf die probleme hier in
sachsen anhalt anders hinweisen als es
die anderen parteien gemacht das haben
wir wesentlich besser gemacht als eine
linkspartei als eine fdp als die grünen
das sieht man ja ganz klar an diesem
ergebnis man kann ja bei 23 5 prozent
nicht von einer wahlniederlage sprechen
wir sind wirklich sehr zufrieden dass
das so funktioniert
ich habe ja auch nicht von der
wahlniederlage sparen das haben sie
jetzt in den mund genommen das wort ihr
erfolg herr pofalla bleibt auf
ostdeutschland beschränkt bei den
letzten landtagswahlen in westdeutschen
bundesländern waren sie zuletzt immer
ein stell ich mir noch mal angeschaut
haben an zustimmung verloren in baden
württemberg wo ihre spitzenkandidatin
kollegen alois seidl angetreten ist
waren das über fünf prozentpunkte
richtet sich die afg als oft parteien
als regionale kraft im osten
nein es gibt ganz normal überall
regionale unterschiede das ist doch bei
jeder anderen partei genauso wie die cdu
hat in den städten zum beispiel auch
ganz andere ergebnisse als auf dem land
wir haben im osten starker ergebnisse
die spd verschwindet in ostdeutschland
von der wähler karte mittlerweile also
daran sieht man doch im prinzip dass
diese unterschiede überall bei allen
parteien auch die gefälle ost west nord
süd das ist ganz normal
aber insgesamt ist politik ein
ausdauerlauf und wir wären auch im
westen zu länger bin mir ziemlich sicher
und das ist für uns motivation auch für
die bundestagswahl
herr copala vielen dank für den besuch
im studio so denkt wir machen hier dann
weiter und haben von der
forschungsgruppe wahlen matthias auch
noch einige analysedaten so sieht es aus
wir haben da gefragt nach den
kompetenzen auch und haben bei den
wichtigsten themen hier
eigentlich immer gesehen dass die afc
eine ziemlich geringe lösungskompetenz
hat oder das ist ja zumindest so
zugewiesen wird
es gibt aber auch eine andere
interessante grafik wenn die afg an der
landesregierung beteiligt wäre dann wäre
die politik besser das sagen immerhin 20
prozent und daran sieht man es ist
natürlich viel protest dabei bei
marseille wählen aber es gibt auch viele
daran glauben dass sich etwas verbessern
kann
das sind natürlich vor allen dingen die
anhänger der afg fast drei viertel
aber ich mag auch einige 18 prozent fdp
anhänger und jetzt schauen wir noch mal
auf das thema corona die aktuell
geltenden corona maßnahmen finden
übertrieben 27 prozent gerade richtig 62
prozent müssten härter sei eine ganz
kleine minderheit und jetzt gucken wir
mal wie das da aussieht übertrieben die
anhänger der afg 60 prozent das ist
schon etwas womit die partei hier sicher
gepunktet hat auch die fdp mit 36
prozent
ganz schön matthias so und jetzt haben
wir inzwischen dass der wahlsieger des
abends reiner haselhoff hier auch auf
dem messegelände in magdeburg angekommen
ist und ich glaube andreas weise hatte
die schon die möglichkeit ihn zu
befragen winter da ich bin überglücklich
und ich freue mich über das vertrauen
und ich verspreche den menschen dass ich
das auch wirklich erfüllen würde was sie
von mir erwarten und was haben die leute
zu einer gegen die hdg wie haben sie
dann die tiere sind sie haben gegen die
auf die gewillt zu großen teilen bis auf
die patienten die dfg hat und sie wissen
womit man das auch ruhig mal dass auch
am besten durchsetzt und das war
sicherlich mit meiner person und damit
auch mit der cdu verbinden gibt es doch
wieder berlin
sie haben als union geschlossen gekämpft
und waren geschlossen auch siegreich und
das ist die botschaft nach berlin
vier jahre danach zurück somit wieder
ins studio
dankeschön andreas so wir erwarten ein
haselhoff dann so kurz vor 19 uhr auch
schon hier im studio und dann natürlich
in der heute sendung jetzt im studio ist
dietmar bartsch fraktionsvorsitzender
der linken im bundestag einer der
spitzenkandidaten auch für die
bundestagswahl
ja das war 2016 schon nicht schön starke
verluste vor fünf jahren
und das setzt sich jetzt fort form kann
ihre partei hier die talfahrt nicht
aufhalten und zunächst mal bin ich froh
dass wir weiterhin auf dem dritten platz
liegen da gab es ganz andere vorhersagen
aber sie haben recht sie haben recht da
gibt es mehrere ursachen eins ist
natürlich die pandemie was für uns ein
problem ist gerade eine partei die sehr
von den gesprächen vor ort lebt da ist
die pandemie besonders hart aber ja ich
bin ein problem einen punkt will noch
zwei weitere nennen der zweite ist diese
polarisierung die auch ein stück weit
inszeniert worden dass haseloff oder afd
wo wir jetzt sehen dass der 14 prozent
dazwischen liegen jetzt natürlich dazu
geführt dass viele gesagt haben so
schlecht soll mein land dann doch nicht
da stehen dann wenig cdu
das habe ich nicht nur einmal gehört und
zuletzt natürlich war der bundestrend
für die linke in sachsen anhalt mit
hilfreich ganz klar aber ich glaube die
sachsen anhaltinische wildsachsen andere
die linke hat einen sehr guten wahlkampf
gemacht und hat vor allem mit dem setzen
des postens themas geschafft woran wir
anschließen können bei der bundesbahn
das ständig wiederum meine nachfrage war
in der tat wenn sie sagen polarisierung
jahr aber sind die verluste der linken
nicht am ende auch eine stabilisierung
der afd
nein das sind sie nicht weil es gibt ja
sehr viele wähler die von der linken
eher zu cdu gegangen sind weil sie
gesagt haben dann will ich doch lieber
die cdu als stärkste partei aber klar
ist wir müssen bei uns nachfragen
wir müssen über unsere politik
nachdenken aber jetzt gilt es natürlich
bei der bundestagswahl ein
entsprechendes ergebnis hinzukriegen
da geht es um die zukunft unseres landes
und da bin ich wiederum optimistisch
weil ich in sachsen anhalt zum schluss
gesehen haben welcher enthusiasmus in
der linken da ist das stimmt mich wie
gesagt optimisten aber pessimistisch
muss ich glaube ich stimmen dass sie ein
stück weit ihre ihre oft kompetenz
verlieren wir neben mahlgrad matthias
fornoff ein paar zahlen dazu aus unseren
analysedaten zur linken
er kümmert sich nicht mehr genug um die
interessen der ostdeutschen
da sehen wir ungefähr so ein fifty fifty
bild 48 prozent stimmen dem zu
44 prozent stimmen dem nicht zu auch
nach parteien sieht man 26 prozent der
linken anhänger stimmen denen nur zu
aber trotzdem ist das ein offenkundiges
problem dass sie so das image der ost
kümmern partei zumindest ein bisschen
wackelt jetzt schauen wir mal auf die
daten der wahltagsbefragung unsere
forschungsgruppe wahlen hat 160
wahllokal den sachsen anhalt die
wählerinnen und wähler befragt und da
sehen wir mal wer wählte die linke denn
nach alter von unter 30 prozent der
unter 30 jährigen verliert sie drei
prozentpunkte bei den 30 bis 44 jährigen
auch drei prozentpunkte und besonders
stark verliert sie bei den älteren bei
45 bis 59 6 punkte und bei den über 60
jährigen sogar sieben prozentpunkte das
ist das hauptproblem offensichtlich was
die altersstruktur betrifft ja danke
matthias und ich will dieses wort noch
einmal aufnehmen herr barth ich oft
kümmert partei diese rolle spielt jetzt
offenbar die afg diese rolle kann die
afg gar nicht spielen weil sich diese
kompetenz nicht hat aber sie haben einen
rechnen das ist ein markenzeichen was
uns ein stück weit verloren gegangen ist
und da bin ich ganz froh dass die partei
hier in sachsen anhalt darauf ein
schwerpunkt gelegt hat nicht nur mit dem
plakat sondern generell indem sie dieses
thema aufgerufen hat wir können doch
nicht zu sehen dass die diskrepanz bei
löhnen immer noch so großes bei renten
die pcie diskrepanz es gibt kein
minister in der bundesregierung aus den
neuen ländern dafür drei aus dem
saarland
es gibt hier nur zwei ost minister ich
wünsche mir dass der hase lauf wenn er
möglichst zügig eine regierung bildet
endlich auch aus kompetenz einbaut das
kann nicht so weitergehen und da sagen
uns die wählerinnen und wähler sehr
deutlich bitte macht das auch in der
kommenden bundestagswahl
auseinandersetzung und das werden wir
diesen auftrag annehmen
diesen wahlkampf vor sich vielen dank
für den besuch im studio strabag danke
so jetzt matthias ja wir haben machen
wir alles selber unterhalten
analysedaten vorheriger analyse zum
wahlsieger cdu und schauen uns das hier
mal an die bewertung von
spitzenpolitikern und partei im land und
im bund das ist wieder die skala die sie
schon kennen von plus 5 bis minus 5
da kommt reiner haseloff ein wert von
plus 2,5 das ist sehr gut
armin laschet kanzlerkandidat der union
neuer so lala plus 0,4
die cdu im land mit starken 2,0 die cdu
im bund wird hier in sachsen anhalt
schlechter eingeschätzt mit 1,5 das ist
sicher ein grund dafür dass die partei
und die person hier gut abgeschnitten
haben es gibt aber noch einen
inhaltlichen und daher bezieht sich auf
den umgang mit der afd
da hat reiner haseloff in der eigenen
partei durchgekämpft dass es keine
zusammenarbeit mit ihr geben soll
und das finden 68 prozent der befragten
genau richtig 29 prozent nicht richtig
jetzt schauen wir doch mal hier durch
die parteien durch natürlich bei der kfd
finden dass die überwiegende mehrheit
schlecht
ansonsten viel zustimmung wir gucken
noch mal auf die wahltagsbefragung und
schauen auch da auf die altersstruktur
wer hat die cdu gewählt hier in sachsen
anhalt da gehen wir gleich mal ans
hintere ende bei den älteren 45 bis 59
und über 60 da sind die haupt zu
gewinnen mit fünf prozentpunkten und
sogar neun prozentpunkten also in dem
segment oder in beiden segmenten wo die
linke so stark verloren hat dankeschön
matthias so wir bleiben dann noch mal
bei der cdu denn da ist natürlich jetzt
auch die frage wie wird es weitergehen
in der koalition
hase läuft braucht trotz aller erfolge
partnern und er wird die wahl haben denn
im moment ist auch die fdp im landtag
die grünen könnten möglicherweise in der
koalition ersetzt werden das wäre dann
von kenia zu einer deutschland koalition
die rechnerisch möglich ist so und auch
dazu hat christina von ungern sternberg
bei der cdu schon ein gesprächspartner
bitte
damit immer bei mir ist stefanie
mittendorf sie ist stadträten hier in
magdeburg frau mittendorf was wäre ihre
wunschkoalition
also ich freue mich erst mal über dieses
tolle ergebnis hoffe natürlich dass ich
das heute abend auch noch weiter festigt
und wünsche dann den beteiligten
natürlich die die cdu mit eine
interaktion tisch holt oder
koalitionstisch gute verhandlungen und
wenn ich persönlich mit entscheidend
dürfte würde ich mir auf jeden fall die
fdp mit dazu wurden und die grünen
würden sie lieber draußen sehen oder
können sie sich eine gemeinsame
regierung verständlich mir tatsächlich
vorstellen also ich bin da eher jemand
der auch natürlich weiß dass es gerade
die jungen leute die jungen studierenden
und akademiker auch sehr grün orientiert
sind und von daher könnte ich mir das
gut vorstellen weil das auch ja ich sag
mal auch eine ambition ist die ich
durchaus teilen kann
auch wenn man an die kinder und die
zukunft bringt auf jeden fall also dann
wäre das sicherlich eine option sagt
stefanie mit vielen dank dass sie bei
uns waren und damit zurück zu euch ins
wahlstudio geht ja danke schön christina
die farbenspiele die werden dieses land
jetzt natürlich begleiten so kurz vor
halb acht das prognose ergebnis ist so
eine knappe halbe stunde alt macht es
immer sinn nach den ersten reaktionen
schon mal ein bisschen innezuhalten
professor karl rudolf korte
er macht das mit uns so fangen wir mal
oben an also das ist tatsächlich ein
erfolg den an denen viele nicht geglaubt
hatten was reiner haseloff hierfür die
cdu eingefahren hat eindeutig in
schwierigen zeiten für ihn auf personen
bezogen hatte sich durch
gesetzt ist auch hier ein macht
revitalisierungsprogramm wie in mainz in
stuttgart auch die menschen wählen
favorisieren das bekannte weniger dass
unbekannte das sieht sich auch in der
pandemie deutlich durch 12 13 punkte vor
der ard also vom kopf an kopf rennen
kann ja eigentlich nicht die rede sein
dennoch bleibt die afg stark also die
cdu sagt offenbar nicht viel von der afg
ab nein oder sie hat offenbar gelernt
ihrem eigenen selbstbewusstsein anders
zu agieren an das symbolisieren vor
allem mit der person nicht zu kopieren
wie der flüchtlingsfrage nicht zu
lavieren nicht belehrend zu sein sondern
mit einem eigenen selbstbewusstsein im
programm darzustellen das kam offenbar
so an dass die distanz zur afg
vergrößert hat aber die ard bleibt auch
hier vor allen dingen nicht nur eine
regionale volkspartei sie ist so eine
zeitreisen partei für die zeit die man
früher vielleicht besser fand weniger
offen weniger liberal weniger modernen
gesellschaft ist hier sehr veränderungs
müde und so wählen dann auch
entsprechend die leute ist also nicht
nur einen protest unabhängig von der
radikalisierung der partei der und der
mitglieder auch im landtag hier zweier
wirbel rhetorik die sich da abgespielt
hat aber die wählerinnen und wähler das
muss man einfach differenzierter sehen
hat in dem zusammenhang der wollen wir
vielleicht kurz mal drauf kommen der ost
beauftragte der cdu eigentlich recht
herr wanda wird der ja gesagt hat diese
starke diktatur erfahrung hat eigentlich
inzwischen den ostdeutschland dazu
geführt dass bestimmte leute nicht mehr
demokratie fähig sind stimmen sie dem zu
machen in dieser radikalität nicht das
ist eine modernisierung auch von
vorurteilen
was stimmt aus fehler sind viel
wählerischer sind weniger an parteien
gebunden das sind also leichter auch
zurückzugewinnen für demokratische
parteien beides ist möglich das licht
demokratische und das demokratische
spektrum
insofern kann man sagen das ist nur ein
teil davon zu treffen
ostdeutsche wählen anders aber die
wahrnehmung ist eine die auf jeden fall
nicht nur durch die vorurteile geprägt
werden sollte sondern es ist etwas
besonders hier in ostdeutschland zu
wählen etwas was man mit dem maßstab mit
westlichen wenn dann so nicht
vergleichen kann
es ist das andere was hier das besondere
ist die erfolge für die cdu die
polarisierung cdu fdp hat natürlich auch
opfer sozusagen gekostet im weiteren
spektrum etwa bei der spd bei grünen
fast schon niederländische verhältnisse
zwei größere partei und kleinstparteien
die daneben sind insofern eine
regierungsbildung die mehrere partner
ganz offensichtlich braucht und die
anderen parteien verliert man fast aus
dem blickfeld weil sie so klein sind und
die grünen können hier nicht rasieren
nein aber sie kommen zum wieder in den
landtag das war kosten auch schon ist
schon ein erfolg für sie zu was ist aber
ein nur geringer berbalk effekt oder was
würden sie wirken sehr gering ist
bisschen auch umfrage hilfe schafft
wieder dankeschön für den moment bis
später professor karl rudolf korte und
das können wir dann direkt vertiefen in
berlin
da ist mir nämlich annalena baerbock die
kanzlerkandidatin der grünen jetzt
zugeschaltet und namens
schönen guten abend ja sie können mich
verstehen
frau berg ja wir haben es gerade gehört
wieder stärker in den umfragen als dann
tatsächlich im ergebnis das erleben auch
sie nicht zum ersten mal keinerlei
rückenwind hier aus sachsen-anhalt
allenfalls so eine kleine brise sie
hätten mehr gebraucht oder sich auch
mehr erhofft
landtagswahlen sind immer sehr
landesspezifisch das haben wir auch in
allen vorangegangenen landtagswahlen
gesehen deswegen die bundestagswahl
da geht es um was anderes da geht es um
eine erneuerung unseres landes nach der
pandemie
aber klar ist wir haben uns in sachsen
anhalt ein bisschen mehr erwünscht auch
wenn wir im vergleich zu 5 jahren
zugelegt haben
aber was glaube ich deutlich geworden
ist wie auch bei den aus deutschen
landtagswahlen zuvor dass viele menschen
dann an der wahlurne gesagt haben
sie wollen nicht dass rechtsextreme eine
regierung mitbestimmen und deswegen die
partei des ministerpräsidenten dann noch
mal stärker gewählt haben als es
vielleicht vorher in den umfragen
deutlich geworden ist ich habe mir die
zahlen auch noch mal angeguckt bis auf
brandenburg wo es 2009 10 mal ein paar
nennenswerte punkte hochging dümpeln die
grünen aus deutschland nach wie vor
ziemlich dahin ist ihre kampagne die er
jetzt ansteht fürs kanzleramt vor allem
eine westdeutsche
nein ganz und gar nicht wir waren in den
letzten jahren ganz ganz viel in
ostdeutschland aber vor allen dingen
auch in ländlichen in
strukturschwächeren regionen unterwegs
ich lebe ja selber in brandenburg mir
ist es ein zentrales anliegen das wir
gerade für gute kitas und schulen eine
gute gesundheitsversorgung anbindung von
bus und bahn in ländlichen
strukturschwächeren räumen sorgen und
die gibt es nunmal überproportional mehr
als in westdeutschland deswegen ist das
ein starker fokus meiner politik und wir
haben in sachsen wir haben in
brandenburg in den letzten jahren
zugelegt und fehlen halt sozusagen
unserer parteigeschichte zehn jahre im
vergleich zu 40 jahren grüne in
westdeutschland ja aber frau bellers sie
kommen mit ihren themen in
ostdeutschland nicht an drei viertel
wärmen die analysedaten gesehen hier in
sachsen anhalt zum beispiel sagen es
gibt wichtigeres als klimaschutz die
arbeit der grünen in der regierung hier
wird mäßig beurteilt auch sie selbst
werden deutlich schlechter als ihre
mitkandidaten im bund die kannst anderen
kanzlerkandidaten scholz und laschet
bewertet welche konsequenzen ziehen sie
daraus für den wahlkampf
dass wir mit unseren themen sehr klar
sehr offen und ehrlich in den wahlkampf
gehen
das bringt aus meiner sicht überhaupt
nicht und das ist auch nicht meine art
politik zu machen
je nach umfragen den menschen was zu
versprechen was man anderswo anders sagt
sondern ich habe eine klare haltung wir
haben klares programm für klimaschutz
mit sozialer gerechtigkeit für eine
starke wirtschaft im 21 jahrhundert und
vor allen dingen für eine starke
daseinsvorsorge und ich glaube man kann
ostdeutschland nicht komplett
übereinkommen ziehen für uns ist es
gerade in sachsen anhalt nicht ganz
einfach aber wir haben zum beispiel in
anderen orten auch in ostdeutschland bei
den letzten landtagswahlen erstmalig
direktmandat zu gefunden
also so eine pauschalisierung das sehe
ich ein bisschen differenzierter aber
klar ist wir haben gerade in anderen
orten des landes im westen im süden und
im norden noch ein paar stärkere
hochburgen sagt annalena baerbock die
grünen kanzlerkandidaten dankeschön nach
berlin so und von den grünen die in der
tat in sachsen anhalt mit sechs prozent
in der prognose schwach abgeschnitten
haben kommen wir zur fdp auf sie hat nur
ganz leichte zugewinne zu verzeichnen
aber die sind entscheidend denn es sieht
so aus dass sie nach zehn jahren
tatsächlich wieder in den landtag in
magdeburg einziehen kann
wir haben
ich höre gerade wir können jetzt zu
linda christian schalten und dort geht
es natürlich linda um die frage wird die
fdp jetzt womöglich die grünen ablösen
in einer künftigen regierung fest steht
mit der fdp gibt es jetzt ganz neue
koalitionsoptionen nach allem was wir
hören können sie sich am besten ein
bündnis aus cdu spd und fdp vorstellen
und da gibt es tatsächlich mehr
gemeinsamkeiten als mit den grünen
vor allem in den punkten landwirtschaft
und verkehr gibt es so viele punkte
da sind sie sich nicht einig und fest
steht denn sie haben erreicht was sie
wollten zehn jahren der
außerparlamentarischen opposition enden
sie sind im rennen und
sie dürfen sich jetzt freuen über das
super ergebnis und das sah um 18 uhr so
aus
keine reaktion da für dieses statement
von der spitzenkandidatin lydia hüskens
ich danke euch allen für den
unglaublichen einsatz in den letzten
monaten
wir haben das zusammen geschafft wir
sind wieder eine fraktion im landtag von
sachsen anhalt
[Applaus]
hier sollen heute abend noch gefeiert
werden und ich gebe damit zurück ins
studio
ja danke schön linda und wärme vorhin
die bilder schon glaube ich gesehen mit
dem jubel einer ihn nicht gehört aber
ich glaube im ergebnis ist das klar
geworden vielen dank linda christan das
können wir jetzt auch vertiefen mit
christian lindner dem
fdp-parteivorsitzenden der mir in berlin
zugeschaltet ist guten abend herr
lindner
guten morgen frau schoss leichte
zugewinne und damit kehrt die fdp nach
zehn jahren zurück in den landtag also
das ziel ist erreicht hätten sie sich
gleich wohl eher lindner so ein bisschen
mehr liberalen bums erhofft sage ich mal
auch als signal jetzt für die
bundestagswahl
ich glaube das signal für die
bundestagswahl ist sehr deutlich mit den
freien demokraten ist in ganz
deutschland in ost und west zu richten
wir freuen und zu rechnen
wir freuen uns darüber dass im
heimatland von hans dietrich genscher
jetzt wieder eine liberale fraktion nach
einem jahrzehnt im parlament vertreten
ist wir haben auch regierungsoptionen
das wird man ja in den nächsten wochen
miteinander besprechen für uns im bund
bestätigt sich unser kurs sehr seriös
aber auch kritisch mit der politik der
großen koalition umzugehen
die fragen der bürgerlichen
freiheitsrechte nach vorne zu rücken
ganz offensichtlich haben unsere
antworten für die wirtschaftliche
belebung
für die modernisierung unserer
wirtschaft viele menschen dort überzeugt
und auf dem kurs werden wir im bund
jetzt nun weitermachen
ja die die liberalen wollen mitregieren
das wollten sie eigentlich ja auch immer
schon künftig im bund jetzt auch hier in
sachsen anhalt sie werden nicht zwingend
gebraucht könnten aber eben
eingewechselt werden zum beispiel für
eine deutschland koalition und
beanspruchen das auch für sich ja die
fragestellung ist ein bisschen schwierig
wie sie jetzt formuliert haben ja wir
stehen zur verfügung für eine
regierungsbildung wenn wir auch inhalte
umsetzen können
und wenn es ein faires miteinander gibt
wir werden aber nicht für irgendjemanden
eingewechselt sondern wir wollen ein
gemeinsames regierungshandeln begründen
aber da liegt jetzt ja die initiative
bei ministerpräsidenten reiner haselhoff
er hat ein sehr gutes ergebnis erzielt
dazu habe ich ihn eben auch gratuliert
es ist ein ergebnis das natürliche auch
auf den letzten metern noch besser sich
dargestellt hat weil die cdu sehr
profitiert hat von einem zumindest
medial diskutierten kopf an kopf rennen
mit der afg das also eine sonder
mobilisierung die es da gegeben hat aber
er hat jetzt den regierungsauftrag mit
einem sehr überzeugenden ergebnis und
man wird genau schauen wie er damit
umgeht hfg anteile herr lindner ich
würde sie gerne danach fragen denn was
was ist ihre haltung in dieser aktuellen
diskussion die ja vom ost beauftragten
der cdu angestoßen wurde muss man die
die hohen werte für die ideen aus
deutschland als gegeben hinnehmen hat
sich da nach ihrem eindruck was auf
dauer verselbstständigt nein ich habe
die äußerungen des ost-beauftragten als
sehr herablassend empfunden auch als
falsch in ihrer pauschalisierung ich bin
dafür dass wir uns das genau ansehen es
gibt einen harten kern von fd
unterstützern die antidemokratisch und
antiliberal sind die völkisches
gedankengut pflegen und die kann man nur
demokratisch bekämpfen
auf der anderen seite habe ich aber bei
meinen veranstaltungen kundgebungen auch
dann im gespräch mit den bürgerinnen und
bürgern erlebt dass es viele menschen
gibt die sich sorgen um die
vernachlässigung des ländlichen raums
defizite bei der digitalisierung dort
etwa die bemängeln dass es in der
bildung nicht vorangeht die sich durch
bürokratismus gegängelt fühlen den
eindruck haben dass politik und medien
in berlin überhaupt gar nicht ihre
themen besprechen und die auch probleme
bei der integration befürchten und mein
vorschlag ist mit diesen menschen die
erreichbar sind zu diskutieren sie nicht
abzuschreiben sondern zu diskutieren
das muss der auftrag das muss das
selbstverständnis aller demokratischen
parteien seien
wir müssen die probleme klein machen die
die afg einst groß gemacht haben und
dann können wir auch einige menschen
fährt wieder in die demokratische mitte
zurückführen
der fdp-parteivorsitzende aus berlin
herzlichen dank dorthin
so und wir haben gehört auch er nimmt
durchaus etwas mit jetzt für den
anstehenden bundestagswahlkampf nämlich
unterstützungen die fdp aller
wahrscheinlichkeit nach wieder im
landtag von magdeburg deshalb gucken wir
jetzt mal genauer mit matthias fornoff
darauf wie denn jetzt eigentlich dieser
bundestrend aussieht was nehmen hier die
parteien mit was wünschen sie sich und
wie haben es eigentlich die sachsen
anhalt arena empfunden ja welche
es ist ja immer einen diese landtagswahl
in sachsen anhalt auch die erste seit
armin laschet als kanzlerkandidat der
union stattfindet das ergebnis wird in
tendenziell stärken aber wir glauben die
wahlberechtigten in sachsen anhalt hat
er auf dieses ergebnis hier eingewirkt
armin laschet ist für das abschneiden
der cdu in sachsen anhalt eher hilfreich
sagen 12 prozent eine mehrheit sagt das
hat keine auswirkung 43 53 prozent
interessant dass es bei den
cdu-anhängern auch nicht viel anders ist
jetzt haben wir unterbrechen haben
hochrechnung von 18 uhr 42 und da sehen
wir die cdu bei 35,2 prozent deutliche
zugewinne
die afd 23,3 prozent etwas verluste die
linke elf prozent 5,3 prozentpunkte
verlust und die spd verliert von ihrem
ohnehin schlechten wert von vom letzten
mal noch einmal 2,4 punkte auf jetzt 82
prozent einstellig die grünen 6,1
prozent kaum verbessert die fdp 6,9
prozent etwas deutlicher verbessert und
wieder im landtag vertreten die freien
wähler schaffen dass sie nicht und
bleiben mit drei prozent unterhalb der
fünf prozent grenze
jetzt kommen wir zur sitzverteilung wir
gehen jetzt zunächst mal von 83 sitzen
außer am ende werden es mehr sein durch
überhang und ausgleichsmandaten
die cdu kommt auf 32 sitze die afg auf
21 linke zehn spd 8 grüne 6 und fdp
ebenfalls sechs sitze wer könnte da mit
wem im brandenburger landtag regieren
hier ist die senkrechte linie 42 sitze
braucht man dafür mindestens das ist die
amtierende kenia koalition die schafft
das locker mit 46 sitzen die deutschland
redakteur deutschland koalition wo die
fdp die grünen praktisch ersetzen würde
kommt ebenfalls auf 46 cdu grüne fdp
also jamaika mit 44 sitzen ebenfalls
drüber
cdu und spd kommt auf 40 sitze relativ
knapp drunter die afg haben wir hier
nicht aufgeführt in diesen möglichkeiten
dies würde natürlich reichen für cdu und
afd das aber ist sehr deutlich vor
vorweg ausgeschlossen worden
vielen dank matthias dass also die erste
hochrechnung und nach der sehen wir 35,2
prozent für die cdu und jetzt wollen wir
auch noch mal eine cdu stimme hören ich
bin nämlich verbunden mit friedrich merz
der mir jetzt zugeschaltet ist
wir erinnern uns eher wahl unterlegen im
kampf um den cdu-parteivorsitz gegen
armin laschet jetzt kandidiert friedrich
merz für den deutschen bundestag ist mir
jetzt digital zugeschaltet herr merz
nahm torchancen nicht grüßen sich nach
berlin also die cdu ist vorn jetzt mal
was für eine botschaft lesen sie daraus
für die cdu und den kanzlerkandidaten im
anstehenden bundestagswahlkampf
auch chancen die botschaft ist klar und
eindeutig die cdu kann noch wahlen
gewinnen und diese landtagswahl hat
unter sehr schwierigen umständen
stattgefunden aber reiner haseloff hat
ein überragendes vertrauen der
bevölkerung in sachsen anhalt gehabt
anspruch nehmen können bei dieser wahl
aber ohne einen bundespolitischen trend
wäre das in dieser form ich übrigens so
stark nicht erwartet hätte ich war
einige mal in sachsen anhalt aber so
starke dies nicht erwartet wäre dies
ohne den trend nicht möglich gewesen das
ist eine eindrucksvolle bestätigung auch
für unseren kanzlerkandidaten armin
laschet insofern an der ausgangslage für
die bundestagswahl müssen das ist nicht
selbstverständlich
das ist ein stück weit auch ein sieg für
armin laschet
sie rechnen also auch nicht damit dass
womöglich noch mal stoff störfeuer aus
münchen kommt damit habe ich nie
gerechnet und nach diesem wahlergebnis
kann da ernsthaft auch niemand mehr mit
rechnen und daran sollte auch
ernsthaften und denken jetzt gucken wir
uns mal dass an der spitze an sie waren
ja in diesem kräftemessen auf der seite
von von laschet in dem kräftemessen
gegen söder gegen den sie ja nun
wiederum zuvor im kampf um den
cdu-parteivorsitz verloren hatten da
haben sie ich glaube das haben alle auch
noch im ohr immer auch mit dem argument
für sich geworben dass die afb wähler
zurückholen können für die cdu glauben
sie das wäre mit ihnen an der
parteispitze jetzt besser geglückt als
man sehen kann
ich habe diese formulierung aus dem jahr
2018 bei meiner ersten bewerbung um den
cdu-parteivorsitz im jahr 2021 bei
meiner zweiten bewerbung nicht
wiederholt und das hat gründe
wir sehen bei einem teil der afg eine
radikalisierung und wie wir heute abend
ja auch anhand der wahlergebnis erstellt
müssen
die spd verliert an die afg deutlich
mehr als mittlerweile die cdu
das ist für uns alle eine
herausforderung aber wenn sie mal
vergleichen die spd hat mal den
ministerpräsidenten sachsen anhalt
gestellt deutlich über 30 prozent der
stimmen gehabt da gab es stehe noch
nicht und jetzt liegt sie im
einstelligen bereich also die verluste
zulasten der spd sind mittlerweile
mittlerweile sicher größer als die
verluste die wir hinnehmen müssen es ist
schmerzt uns alle aber ich habe diese
formulierung genau aus diesem grunde
eben wiederholt sie ist mittlerweile
sogar zwei jahre alt die spd wird
sicherlich auch bei einer solchen klaren
polarisierung an die cdu verloren haben
als juniorpartner in einer regierung das
ist ohnehin schwierig das weiß man auch
aus dem mund ich will aber noch mal
nachfragen bestätigt sich auch aus ihrer
sicht heute das eben es für den kurs der
abgrenzung also brandmauer hoch
gegenüber der afg für die cdu gar keine
alternative gibt es gibt immer
alternativen in der demokratie aber das
ist die richtige entscheidung
eine ganz klare abgrenzung nach
rechtsaußen eine ganz klare aussage von
reiner haseloff ich habe mit ihm darüber
viel gesprochen ich hab's geteilt mit
ihnen eine ganz ganz klare abgrenzung
das für uns eine zusammenarbeit egal in
welcher form mit dieser partei nicht in
frage kommt und wenn sie die
wortmeldungen der letzten tage auch des
heutigen tages aus der afg hören dann
kann man für einen christdemokraten nur
sagen wir verstehen wir dann auch warum
es gibt diese arbeit nicht und das war
ein richtig müsste dann herr merz auch
der parteivorsitzende lasche noch
strikter diesen kurs verfolgen im umgang
mit etwa mit den kandidaten maßen in
thüringen mit der so genannten werte
union und dem neuen vorsitzenden orte
gehören beide aus ihrer sicht in die cdu
da müsste nicht da auch ein stück weit
abgrenzung schärfer löschen
ich weiß nicht was armin laschet noch
schärfer und noch klarer sagen soll
es gibt eine ganz klare abgrenzung nach
rechts außen
das spektrum der cdu ist relativ breit
wie breit müssen wir sicherlich in jedem
einzelfall diskutieren solange sich die
der cdu als mitglieder dabei sind zu
unserem grundsatzprogramm und unseren
grundsätzen und überzeugungen bekennen
ist das okay wenn sie außerhalb stehen
stehen sie außerhalb aber armin laschet
hat das nun glaube ich in den letzten
tagen hinreichend deutlich gesagt rainer
haseloff auch ich auch die sind uns in
diesen tagen in der cdu alle sehr sehr
eins herzlichen gang friedrich markt zu
den ergebnissen der cdu hier in sachsen
anhalt und darüber hinaus und jetzt
schauen wir noch mal auf die spd ein in
der tat enttäuschender abend werden den
enttäuschen generalsekretär im eingangs
schon gehört und gehen jetzt zu carsten
behrendt der genau diese enttäuschung
auch beobachtet
der bettina als hier die balken nach
unten gegangen sind erneut nach den
schlechten ergebnis von vor fünf jahren
da war es sehr schlagartig vorbei mit
der biergarten stimmung und erst als die
spitzenkandidatin katja pele dann hier
eingetroffen ist da gab es ein jubel und
zwar so doll dass sie sehr emotional
angefasst war und dann auch kurz weinen
musste und in dieses statement kommerz
mal reinhören
genossen dankeschön dankeschön für einen
wahlkampf den wir mit 41 kandidierenden
überall im land mit unglaublicher
solidarität mit unglaublichem engagement
hingelegt haben
ich habe euch auf dem nächsten parteitag
einen geilen wahlkampf versprochen
und den haben wir hingekriegt und es ist
euer verdienst herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
gleichzeitig eine bittere pille für die
spd und es herrscht da eine große
ratlosigkeit warum die partei einfach
bei den wählern nicht punkten kann und
es nur noch einmal nach unten gegangen
ist
dankeschön carsten ja da liegen
natürlich auch emotionen dann frei an so
einem wahlabend natürlich auch nachhaken
wahlkämpfen da ist es vielleicht auch
gut wenn jemand das aus der entfernung
sei ein bisschen mit abstand beobachtet
das wollen wir jetzt besprechen mit
norbert walter borjans dem
spd-bundesvorsitzenden schönen guten
abend herr walter borjans also das ist
gar nicht schönzureden
wie nennt man das sehr weiter bayern
sind sie spd sehen wir unter die räder
geraten oder ja ich glaube wir sind
schlicht und ergreifen sind ein
windschatten geraten
vorab aber nochmal einen glückwunsch an
den amtierenden ministerpräsidenten
reiner haseloff das gehört sich so er
hat die wahl gewonnen und er hat sich
vor allen dingen auch gewonnen weil er
sich persönlich klar gegen rechts
positioniert hat und das hat eben zu
diesem windschatten geführt wir haben
eine polarisierung zwischen der person
des ministerpräsidenten und den kräften
die die afc im land ausmachen
rechtspopulisten und da haben
da kann ich ihm nur zustimmen das
bekannte gesicht gewählt und haben sich
dafür entschieden und das erstes mal ein
gewinn dass die demokratie im land
gestärkt und nicht geschwächt worden ist
aber wie gesagt der der windschatten
die parteien dazwischen hatten extreme
probleme sich gerade auch noch unter
corona bedingungen bemerkbar zu machen
und das hat zu diesem ergebnis geführt
dass uns sicher alles andere als
glücklich macht ihr kanzlerkandidat olaf
scholz hat die hier im land wenn man
immer nach den kanzlerkandidaten im
vergleich gefragt hat gute respektable
werte aber so ein partei ergebnis wie
hier jetzt in sachsen anhalt das ist
natürlich ein rückschlag woher soll
jetzt der walter borjans der das
aufbruchsignal kommen für den
bundestagswahlkampf für olaf scholz
also nochmal ich kann nur sagen und das
mache ich nicht weil wir jetzt schlecht
abgeschnitten haben das habe ich immer
gesagt es wert würde auch für den fall
eines sehr guten abschneidens gelten
hier haben die landespolitischen themen
im vordergrund gestanden
sie hat diese polarisierung von der ich
eben gesprochen habe im vordergrund
gestanden
aber sie hat ja eben auch ein signal zum
ausdruck gebracht nämlich dass es keinen
sozialen nationalismus gibt sondern dass
offenheit das eine ein ja zur demokratie
das richtige ist und wir bleiben dabei
wir wollen und wir müssen zeigen dass
etwas sehr kompliziertes zum erklären
aber das richtige ist nämlich dass der
soziale das wirtschaftlich dynamische
und das ökologische nur zusammengedacht
werden können
anders funktioniert es nicht und wir
bleiben dabei dass olaf scholz auch mit
dem respekt den sachsen anhalt genießt
richtige ist er das verkörpert und dafür
vertrauen auch auf der bundesebene hat
ganz kurz nach muss die lehrer auch
seien für die spd raus aus der regierung
eine die opposition hier in sachsen
anhalt war die juniorpartnerschaft jetzt
sozusagen auch das ende
naja ich habe nie ein hehl gemacht dass
das eine schwere überwindung war als ich
an der großen koalition zu beteiligen
und wir sehen dass das sicher
zwar viele ergebnisse gebracht hat in
den knapp vier jahren aber dass wir
jetzt auf der anderen seite deutlich
machen müssen wir müssen unsere ziele in
den vordergrund stellen so viel wie
möglich für unser programm gewinnen und
dann wird man sehen müssen ob das in
einer koalition ist und wenn die
schnittstellen und die schnittmengen
nicht reichen muss man auch bereit sein
zu sagen dann profiliert man diese
themen eben außerhalb
danke schön herr walter bayern nach
berlin das war der spd
bundesvorsitzender so und von der spd
gehen wir noch mal zur afd
die hier mit 23 3 in unserer ersten
hochrechnung gerechnet wird also ein
starkes ergebnis andreas weise hat den
spitzenkandidaten draußen schlange
sprache meiner seite oliver kirchner
spitzenkandidat und fraktionschef der
npd im sachsen-anhaltischen landtag
herr kirchner deutlich über 20 prozent
sind sie trotzdem enttäuscht dass es
nicht für den ersten platz gereicht
hatte nein bin ich nicht enttäuscht aber
ich habe ja immer den fokus gestellt
dass das land ja konservativ wählen soll
und auch will und das hat es getan und
ich bin mit diesen 22,5 prozent durchaus
zufrieden weil wir ja ich sage mal auch
nicht unbedingt mit positiven
überraschungen rechnen konnten
wir wollen mit hetze überhaupt wir haben
fünf jahre lang sind wir teilweise
totgeschwiegen worden
und dann muss ich ihnen sagen 22 5
prozent finde ich das schon sehr gut
aber es gibt ja eine konservative
mehrheit in sachsen anhalt aber würden
es wird ja niemand wird die cdu hat es
abgelehnt dass er nicht schlimm da
machen wir wieder unsere arbeit wir
vorher gemacht haben haben wir sehr gut
gemacht
sonst hätten wir ja auch nicht diese 22
5 prozent der hand ist noch lang und ich
muss sagen wenn die bürger ebenso
gewählt haben dann haben sie nie wieder
so in ordnung
wichtig für uns war dass wir von den
linken unserer arbeit wieder zurückholen
und bei dem einen trinken der linken von
fast fünf prozent glaube ich war das
auch schon erfolg für uns weil wir genau
diese wählerschicht natürlich auch bei
uns haben wollen
vielen dank an kirchen ab und zurück ins
wahlstudio
dankeschön andreas und herr kirchner
wird grad gleich auch in unserer 19 uhr
spitzenkandidaten runde sein genauso wie
auch der wahlsieger dieses abends der
ministerpräsident reiner haseloff der
jetzt dankenswerterweise schon vorab zu
uns gekommen ist so dass wir ein paar
minuten haben der hase läuft so also das
ist ein fulminanter erfolg den in der
höhe niemand erwartet hatte wie groß ist
ihre erleichterung heute an leistung ist
groß und die freude ebenfalls ist es in
dieser deutlichkeit auch nicht von mir
erwartet worden ob er hat gekämpft man
hat das gefühl man hatte in den letzten
tagen auch eine zuwendung erfahren so
nach dem motto das muss klappen das wird
klappen aber letztendlich entscheidet
der wahltag und dann muss man abends auf
10 uhr gruppen was frau schiffer müssten
nun haben wir gerade friedrich merz
interessanterweise gehört er sagt also
das war ein eindeutiger wahlerfolg und
wahlsieg von reiner haselhoff aber am
ende auch ein erfolg der bundesspitze
der partei spitze also ist das jetzt
auch ein sieg für armin laschet hat er
ihnen schon gratuliert natürlich schon
gratuliert und man muss auch sehen klar
ist es ein landtagswahlkampf der hat
sozusagen die letzte landtagswahl vor
der bundestagswahl gesetzt und das hat
natürlich auch eine signalwirkung auf
der anderen seite muss man auch klar
sagen dass wir geschlossen aufgetreten
sind cdu und csu das muss man wissen und
dass auch die cdu spitze
armin laschet auch sehr sehr starke
unterstützung gegeben hat und deswegen
haben wir alle davon etwas und das ist
ein zeichen auch dafür dass wir
geschlossen sind wir im september
gewinnen können im unions wahlkampf
hatten sie gleichwohl auf söder gesetzt
von dem sie offenbar erwartet hatten
dass er ihnen mehr schub bringen könnte
lang sie damit falsch ist dass der wir
leben heute habt mich ist wenn wir
mehrere möglichkeiten haben mehrere gute
leute und es ist klar dass man in einer
volkspartei darüber diskutiert mit wem
man ins rennen gehen will
man kennt die affinitäten seiner region
nun ist sachsen anhalt nicht
repräsentativ für deutschland ihr für
ostdeutschland
von gespannten zumindestens und dieses
signal muss man rüber bringen
aber letztendlich entscheidet nach nicht
nur die demokratische verfahren sondern
letztendlich muss man auch abwägen in
einer cdu deutschlands und in einer cdu
csu als union mit wem man in
gesamtdeutschland gewinnen kann und da
ist die entscheidung gefallen also sie
haben sich da jetzt nicht zu korrigieren
kann ich habe mich doch nicht zu
korrigieren ganz im gegenteil das sind
alles freunde von mir und wir haben
erfolgreich wahlkampf gemacht sicherlich
ist vieles auch durch uns als cdu mit
allen die wahlkämpfer gewesen sind und
wahlkämpferin gewesen sind hier
erfolgreich gewesen und und belaufen
auf der anderen seite haben wir uns
gestärkt und verstärkt und das ist genau
die botschaft nach berlin
nur gemeinsam können wir gewinnen und
kann armin laschet irgendwas von ihnen
lernen ich glaube gar nicht auseinander
was die integrationsfähigkeit anbelangt
und auch das grundverständnis zu
christlich sozialer politik und auch zur
arbeitsmarktpolitik und diesen dingen
jeder hat seine eigene spezifik das ist
auch wiederum klar hat gelernt bei mir
dass man auch in bereiche hineingehen
muss die es in dieser form so nicht gibt
er hat ja auch problembereiche zum
beispiel in westen von nordrhein
westfalen
die sind aber völlig anders strukturiert
als bei uns zb die aufgehoben und das
muss man einfach zur kenntnis nehmen und
wir müssen auch die themen besser
identifizieren mit denen man menschen
zurückholen kann in die demokratische
mitte und das sind eben themen die
ähnlichen box diskutiert werden die in
mieten die medien in der westdeutschen
medienwelt wir haben fast eine
ausschließliche westdeutsche medienwelt
was auch die standorte auch anbelangt
nicht jetzt öffentlich rechtlichen
sondern generell nimmt auch so sagen
gibt ja den blick auf deutschland und
auch aus deutschland
darf man eben sich auch mehr mühe geben
muss in die köpfe dieser menschen rein
zu kommen damit wir eine chance haben
sie wieder für die demokratie zu
gewinnen der ministerpräsident reiner
haseloff für den moment wir schauen auf
die uhr wir gehen jetzt zunächst zu 19
uhr heute sendung darf sie schon rüber
bitten vielen dank für den moment und
wir machen jetzt in mainz weiter im
studio also ein interessanter wahlabend
hier in sachsen anhalt der letzte
politische stimmungstest vor der
bundestagswahl
und wer mit einem kopf an kopf rechnen
rennen zwischen cdu und fdp rechnet
hatte sah sich enttäuscht wie die
forschungsgruppe auch vorhergesagt hatte
ist der abstand doch deutlich die cdu
vorn und jetzt geben wir zunächst nach
mainz unserer 19 uhr heute sendung und
barbara hahlweg bis gleich die junge
beide cdu die partei von
ministerpräsident haseloff bleibt in
sachsen anhalt deutlich stärkste kraft
klar vor der afd
die fdp ist wohl zurück im landtag land
im sorge in großbritannien breitet sich
die besonders ansteckende indische
variante des corona virus immer weiter
aus und land unter heftige unwetter
haben in großen teilen deutschlands
chaos ausgelöst
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen an diesem wahlsonntag sport
gibt es auch in der sendung mit rudi
cerne hallo schön genannt das von der
afg angestrebte beben in sachsen anhalt
ist ausgeblieben die cdu von
ministerpräsident reiner haseloff hat
das rennen um die stärkste kraft im land
klar für sich entschieden
die afg bleibt auf platz zwei
enttäuschend sind die ergebnisse für die
mitregierenden spd und grünen
die fdp schafft es wohl erstmals nach
zehn jahren wieder in den landtag
matthias fornoff ist in unserem wald
studio in magdeburg matthias wie sehen
die aktuellen zahlen aus japan täglich
zu 19 uhr gibt es frische zahlen hier
ist die zweite hochrechnung danach kommt
die cdu auf 35,5 prozent und gewinnt
deutlich dazu der kfd auf 23,1 mit
verlusten die linke mit 10,9 prozent und
deutlichen verlusten
die spd 8,1 prozent also einstellig und
nochmal mit verlusten 2,5 punkte
die grünen 6 prozent mit geringfügigen
zu gewinnen die fdp 6,7 prozent ist
wieder drin im landtag nach zehn jahren
und die freien wähler haben es nicht
geschafft bleiben bei 3% jetzt schauen
wir mal auf die sitzverteilung im
landtag von magdeburg 83 sitze gibt es
da mindestens es wird aber wohl überhang
und ausgleichsmandaten geben das
tangiert aber nicht das kräfteverhältnis
also können wir damit rechnen die cdu
kommt demnach auf 33 sitze die afc auf
21 linke zehn spd 7 grüne 6 und fdp 6
und die absolute mehrheit läge dann bei
42 sitzen wir gucken mal was das für das
regieren hieße die amtierende kenia
regierung aus cdu spd und grünen käme
auf 46 sitze und damit deutlich über die
42 die man mindestens braucht wäre die
fdp mit in der regierung statt den
grünen die sogenannte deutschland
koalition ging es ebenfalls auf 46 und
es würde reichen
jamaica cdu grüne fdp 45 sitze auch das
würde reichen
eine ehemals große koalition muss man
sagen aus cdu und spd aber würde es
nicht schaffen das sind
tatsächlich sitzen dort noch zur
wahlbeteiligung sie lag ziemlich genau
so wie vor fünf jahren bei 61 prozent
dankeschön matthias fornoff die frage
wer mit wem wird auch die
spitzenkandidaten und
spitzenkandidatinnen umtreiben die sind
jetzt bei bettina schausten und unserem
landes korrespondenten andreas weise
versammelt bettina zumindest
ministerpräsident haseloff ist ja
überglücklich wir vorhin sagte die
überglückliche alle sind hier versammelt
ich muss nochmal einmal zur erklärung
sagen natürlich mit abstand den halten
wir pandemie bedingt dann doch noch ein
wenig arbeiten haseloff hat das rennen
gemacht mit deutlichem abstand zur afg
sie können sich bestätigt sehen und
sehen bestätigt auch ihre koalition mit
der sie sachsen anhalt hier regieren
kenia koalition
das ist richtig ich glaube hier regiert
bei allen ecken und kanten die wir
täglich im vollsuff sicherlich auch
hatten hat das ganze fünf jahre gehalten
und hat gezeigt dass demokratische
parteien in der mitte auch eine
koalition durchführen können auch wenn
sie so noch nicht erprobt wurde in
deutschland das war die erste in
deutschland die wir gemacht haben und
die karussells um einerseits und auch
die ganze zeit über die koalition nach
rechts hin hat das denke ich mal
auch noch mal gestand wir wissen dass
das wahlergebnis abwarten dass hier noch
die briefwahlstimmen und da muss man
schauen welche optionen sich ergeben man
wird wirklich in aller sachlichkeit nur
danach geschaut was fürs land gut
ich denke wir sind nicht gut beraten uns
irgendwie instrumentalisieren zu lassen
von bundesthemen oder voneinander
bundestagswahl was könnte dort
konstellationen mäßig günstig für den
orthopäden sein
es geht um sachsen anhalt und deswegen
werden wir in ruhe miteinander sprechen
oliver kirchner spitzenkandidat der afd
sie hatten schon als ziel platz eins
ausgegeben haben leicht verloren sind
sie enttäuscht heute
ich hatte das ziel nicht ausgegeben ich
habe immer gesagt zwischen 39 und 26
würde ich mir
ich bin überhaupt nicht enttäuscht ich
bin froh darüber wir sind volkspartei im
osten andere sind es nicht mehr
wir haben es die wähler der linken
zurück geholt die arbeiter das wollten
wir schaffen und deswegen bin ich hier
sehr zufrieden
die spitzenkandidatin der linken vor
fünf jahren bereits kräftig verloren
jetzt geht die talfahrt weiter
und man hat das gefühl die linke ist
wird nicht mehr wahrgenommen als
statthalter deutscher interessen warum
konnten sie den abwärtstrend nicht
stoppen
ich bedaure natürlich das ergebnis was
wir heute eingefahren haben neben aber
auch zur kenntnis dass es auch teil des
der der cdu kampagne cdu rhabarber reihe
ist also wir haben da insbesondere spd
grüne und auch wir als linke haben da
erheblich verloren
ich habe es für verantwortungslos
gehalten weil sachsen anhalt ist kein
nazi land der ministerpräsident war sie
aber nicht zu schade um macht zu
erhalten uns genau an dieser ecke zu
schieben und ich erwarte jetzt von ihm
das jetzt zeitnah eine landesregierung
bildet und nicht so wie schon von der
cdu im landtag geäußert dass man noch
warten wolle bis nach der bundestagswahl
wo wir dann alle nicht wissen ob er
nicht doch möglicherweise diesen
rechtskonservativen weg geht also da
sehe ich jetzt seine verantwortung und
auch vor allem nach dem was hier in den
letzten tagen seinerseits auch vollzogen
worden ist ich bin gespannt wie ihr das
macht nachdem er gestern erst noch
geäußert hat dass alle die nicht cdu
gewählt haben diesen land geschadet
haben
das ist demokratiefeindlich aber das ist
jetzt mein job
nicht darin wie sie es gerne haben
wollten der balkan wird noch fortgesetzt
nehmen wir hier war andreas kath appelle
spitzenkandidatin der spd wieder
verloren diesmal einstellig und das
obwohl sie eigentlich in der
regierungspartei relativ gute kritiken
bekommen indem regierungsarbeit gute
kritiken bekommen haben was wir
konsequenzen müssen sie jetzt daraus
ziehen
ich stelle einfach fest es auch das
ergebnis der spd ein ergebnis ist mit
dem wir nicht zufrieden sein können es
aber tatsächlich auch dem umstand
geschuldet ist dass es hier im land auch
in den prognosen eine polarisierung
zwischen cdu und fdp gegeben hat und ich
weiß dass viele wählerinnen und wähler
überlegt haben wenn sie denn tatsächlich
wählen können um die afg atomkraft hier
im land zu verhindern und deshalb finde
ich es demokratisch betrachtet gut dass
die stimmung bei der cdu gelandet sind
für meine partei ist es aber sehr sehr
bedauerlich zähle aber gleichzeitig auch
noch auf die briefwähler
das heißt am ende des abends marktes
ergebnis noch anders aussehen als
aktuell
cornelia lüddemann von den grünen
regierungsmitglied das hat ihr nicht
genutzt
sie konnten jedenfalls nicht zu legen
wie man das vielleicht hätte erwarten
können wenn man im bund eine
kanzlerkandidaten aufstellt warum hat es
hier nicht geklappt und wir wollen sie
vor allem sicherstellen dass sie weiter
in der regierung mit dabei sind
es ist zunächst einmal will ich
feststellen dass wir dazu gewonnen haben
wir sind in einem ostdeutschen
bundesland das ist traditionell nicht
einfach für die grünen wir hätten uns
natürlich gewünscht dass wir noch
deutlich mehr zu stimmenzugewinne haben
um den klimaschutz auch in einer
nächsten regierung deutlich stärker
vorantreiben zu können
ich hoffe dass es nach auszählung der
briefwahlstimmen noch ein bisschen nach
oben geht aber tatsächlich hätte ich mir
mehr für klimaschutz an der stelle
gewünscht
lydia hüskens spitzenkandidatin der fdp
zehn jahre hat es gedauert jetzt sind
sie wieder im landtag
welche rolle wollen sie im landtag
vielleicht sogar auch in der
landesregierung spielen ja welche rolle
wir spielen können werden wir sehen wenn
man das wahlergebnis haben und zum ist
es die umfragen zeigen ja dass es
unterschiedliche möglichkeiten gibt da
ist für uns dann wichtig welches projekt
welche ziele hat man für sachsen anhalt
wie können wir 600 voranbringen
und wenn wir überzeugt sind dass das
dann auch ein sinnvolle überlegung
dann sind ja auch bereit verantwortung
zu übernehmen im gang so wir haben gut
drei monate bis zur bundestagswahl von
daher haseldorf wissen auch sie das hier
heute sehr genau aus sachsen-anhalt
geschaut wird was für ein signal sagen
sie geht richtung bund richtung armin
laschet von diesem wahlabend aus wurde
erstens mal muss man als cdu sorgen wenn
wir geschlossen arbeiten und geschlossen
auftreten mit der csu gemeinsam kann man
erfolgreich sein das ist eigentlich die
botschaft geschlossenheit kann im
prinzip das rezept sein damit man auch
die bundestagswahl gewinnt auf der
anderen seite muss man eben auch die
spezifischen besonderheiten des
jeweiligen landes einer jeweiligen
region auch im bundestagswahlkampf sehr
genau zur kenntnis nehmen und da gibt es
im osten spezifika wenn man sich nicht
richtig erkennt und aufgreift wo ich aus
dann zum problem werden können wenn man
das wahlergebnis am 26 september sieht
also wäre ihr rad den ostdeutschland
nicht zu vergessen im bundestag kann
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe ich aber
in westdeutschland wird man kanzler
ostdeutschland wird verhindert obmann
kanzler wird soweit unsere
spitzenkandidaten runde aus magdeburg
heute abend zurück ins studio zu ballweg
dankeschön sie hans gehört sachsen
anhalt sie haben es gehört das ist der
letzte wahltermin vor der bundestagswahl
im september also eine art ultimativer
stimmungstest besonders aufmerksam
verfolgen entsprechend die
parteizentralen in der hauptstadt die
einlaufenden ergebnisse hier die ersten
reaktionen von verlieren und gewinnen
aus berlin
es ist ein persönlicher sieg vor reiner
haseloff aber des ganzen teams der cdu
in sachsen-anhalt wir haben auch als cdu
deutschlands gemeinsam mit den freunden
von gekämpft insofern ein starker
kandidat ein klares profil der mitte und
geschlossenheit das war ausschlaggebend
es gibt mittlerweile in sachsen anhalt
nur noch zwei volksparteien das ist die
cdu und das ist die afd
also das zeigt doch eigentlich ganz klar
was die was die bürger in sachsen anhalt
wollen eine regierung aus cdu und fdp
haben deutlich an stimmen verloren und
haben unsere wahlziele nicht erreicht
wir sind
dass wir uns dass uns natürlich nicht
zufrieden stellen kann und deswegen ist
es ein enttäuschendes ergebnis für uns
das ist kein schönes ergebnis
wir hatten uns deutlich mehr erhofft es
gab viele menschen in sachsen anhalt die
gerade bei diesem kopf an kopf rennen
zwischen haseloff und der hfc was die
letzten tage ja sichtbar war da haben
viele dann gesagt dann wählen wir jetzt
ein haseloff weil wir nicht wollen dass
die hft in sachsen anhalt stärkste kraft
wird an tags wahlen sind immer sehr
landesspezifisch das haben wir auch in
allen vorangegangenen landtagswahlen
gesehen deswegen die bundestagswahl
da geht es um was anderes da geht es um
eine erneuerung unseres landes nach der
pandemie
aber klar ist wir haben uns in sachsen
anhalt ein bisschen mehr erwünscht auch
wenn wir im vergleich zu 5 jahren
zugelegt haben
nach über zehn jahren werden jetzt
wieder freie demokraten im landtag von
sachsen anhalts vertreten sein
im heimatland von hans dietrich genscher
gibt es nun wieder eine liberale
parlamentsfraktion und darüber freuen
wir uns über die landesgrenzen von
sachsen-anhalt hinaus die wahl in
sachsen anhalt gleich nach uns geht es
weiter mit der berichterstattung live
aus magdeburg alle entwicklungen gibt es
auch online in unserem live blog zur
wahl in der zdf- heute- app
gesundheitsminister sparen hatif soweit
also die 19 uhr heute kollegin wir
machen jetzt hier weiter mit der
berichterstattung über die wahl in
sachsen anhalt wir haben die ergebnisse
gesehen ein klarer sieg für die cdu die
afg konnte sich mehr oder weniger bei
ihrem ergebnis halten andere parteien
wie die spd die linke die grünen haben
verloren
die fdp ist zurück in den land im
landtag in magdeburg darüber sprechen
wer es in der nächsten stunde unter
anderem mit unserer korrespondentin
nicole diekmann in berlin die das ganze
beobachtet hat für uns nicole das ganze
hat was mit der bundespolitik zu tun das
haben wir heute schon ausreichend
besprochen fast doch noch einmal kurz
zusammen wie die verschiedenen parteien
jetzt reagiert haben auf dieses ergebnis
aus magdeburg naja es ist das alte lied
der sieg hat viele väter eine niederlage
ist ein waisenkind also wenn man anna
lena
berbalk hört kanzlerkandidaten der
grünen dann war das eine reine
landtagswahl
wer noch nicht weiß wie die grünen
abgeschnitten haben kann es daraus lesen
also nicht so wie erhofft
reiner haseloff hingegen
ministerpräsident der
höchstwahrscheinlich auch bleiben wird
mit einem viel größeren abstand zur afg
als umfragen zum teil vorher gesagt
haben und 35 prozent ist glaube ich
jetzt im moment so dass wo sich die cdu
einpendelt das ist für ihn natürlich ein
großer erfolg das ist ein erfolg für ihn
auch in seiner haltung gegenüber der af
deser ganz klar die vielzitierte
brandmauer immer wieder gezogen hat auch
gegen den widerstand aus eigenen reihen
im adenauer-haus v10 jahr kamen wir eben
gesehen beansprucht man diesen erfolg
auch für sich auch für armin laschet den
kanzlerkandidaten der sicherlich
einigermaßen erleichtert sein wird denn
er ist ja auch in der union nicht ganz
unumstritten gewesen sagt nicht so fest
im sattel das ist für ihn jetzt
rückenwind also werde heute gut
abgeschnitten hat wie zum beispiel cdu
und fdp spricht von einem wahlergebnis
das über die landesgrenzen hinaus
bedeutung hat und diejenigen bei denen
es nicht so gut gelaufen ist
die schieben den schwarzen peter daneben
er den lang zu aber interessanterweise
hatten wir ja auch gerade bei matthias
fornoff haben wir das gesehen eine
umfrage
und da wurde festgestellt also wurden
die befragten befragt zu welchen
einfluss hatte als armin laschet auf das
wahlergebnis und ich glaube über 50
prozent sagten eigentlich ist es
unerheblich
das heißt macht sich die cdu im bund da
ja im grunde ohne berechtigung den sieg
zu eigen
naja also die cdu ist keine kein verein
von demoskopen und demoskopen die cdu
eine partei die man natürlich politik
unsere politik gehört auch pr natürlich
will man dies jetzt so deuten dass es
auch nach außen hin das signal geht
schaut mal ihr würdet auf den sieger
setzten liebe wählerinnen und wähler
wenn ihr uns im september auch im bund
wählen würde
jetzt haben wir gesehen die spd und die
grünen die haben doch sehr klar verloren
das war teilweise er
dass die nicht so stark abschneiden aber
dass es dann doch so eindeutig ist das
ist dann doch irgendwie überraschungen
oder ja es ist einigermaßen überraschend
wobei ja ja die grünen also dieser ganz
große aufwind den arena werburg
mitgebracht hat als sie dann zur
kanzlerkandidatin erklärt wurde auch
noch in einer woche in der markus söder
und armin laschet zerstrittene spitzen
der schwesterparteien cdu und csu
aufgetreten sind
der ist ja zum teil schon wieder
abgeebbt
acht punkte gewonnen also die linke und
die spd haben vor allem verlor ja genau
die grünen hatten sich einfach nur mehr
ein
und er hofft weil sie eben diesen
rückenwind er mitnehmen wollten so
sieht's aus deswegen das ist nicht so
überraschend dass es jetzt nicht so viel
war wie man sich dass ausgerechnet hat
er die letzten tage gab es nochmal viel
wirbel um annalena baerbock weil ein
journalist auf ihren lebenslauf gestoßen
war und die den im nachhinein dann in
einigen punkten korrigiert hat ja bei
der spd
also dann war man noch sei das jubelt
bei den sozialdemokratinnen weil olaf
scholz kanzlerkandidat der spd ein sieg
aus ihrer aus ihrer sicht herum hatte
durch eine globale steuer
unternehmenssteuer
ob das jetzt den wähler die wählerin in
sachsen anhalt so stark interessiert das
war schon gestern im großen fragezeichen
versehen heute können wir sagen nein
überhaupt gar nicht ist überraschend
weil die mit in der regierung sitzen ja
in sachsen anhalt aber es scheint der
alte flucht zu sein der spd regieren das
auch von den leuten kotiert wird schlägt
sich nicht in den um in den in den
wahlergebnissen wider so ich habe jetzt
hier in den kommentaren wie schon den
ganzen abend über die beschwerde wir
würden besonders die afg zensieren das
ist nicht so jegliche ganz klare
positionierung pro oder kontra eine
partei werden wir hier entfernen an so
einem wahlabend das heißt sowohl
kommentare die heißen pro afd als auch
kommentare
ofd fliegen hier einfach raus ihr könnt
euch das sparen sonst haben wir einfach
viel zu klicken
das machen wir schon den ganzen abend
jetzt wollen wir bei der afg das war ja
ganz interessant gerade wie tino kruppa
einer der sprecher der afg das ganze für
sich eingeordnet hat wenn ich hier in
die kommentare gucke stelle ich fest je
nachdem wie man die partei findet sagen
die einen
yes wir haben's gerissen und die anderen
sagen ihr habt ihr nicht weil eigentlich
hätte tier laut umfragen vielmehr haben
sollen was willst du jetzt sagen hat die
afd
da jetzt heute tatsächlich punkt gemacht
oder würde man sagen ja eigentlich wer
da noch mehr drin gewesen
naja also was man tatsächlich unbedingt
finde ich an diesem abend konzertieren
muss ist die afg in sachsen-anhalt ist
in diesem wahlkampf sehr radikal
aufgetreten
vielleicht so radikal wie noch kein
anderer landesverband vor er und sie
wird vom dortigen verfassungsschutz
beobachtet trotzdem haben immer noch
mehr als 20 prozent der leute die heute
wählen gegangen ist für die afg gestimmt
das ist natürlich eine aussage das ist
für die aus wie die afg die ich seit
jahren im hauptstadt riga als
korrespondentin beobachte die ja auch
seit jahren einen richtungsstreit in
sich führt das ist nochmal rückenwind
für die rechtsaußen zu denen unter
anderem hans thomas schneider gehört der
zur afg sachsen gehört er dem
landesvorstand angehört der explizit als
person vom bundesverfassungsschutz
beobachtet wird das ist ein relativ
seltenes phänomen das zeigt also der
rechts drei der afg der dürfte nach
dieser nach diesem ergebnis in
sachsen-anhalt weiter gehen tino keller
versucht es ja als die als die
zustimmung der wähler innen für eine
bürgerliche politik zu erklären
das ist aber eine sehr gewagte aussage
wenn man sich anguckt nochmal wie die
afg in sachsen-anhalt aufgestellt ist
auch inhaltlich
jetzt gibt es hier verschiedene fragen
die genauso eine koalition zwischen cdu
und fdp matti sieren haben wir gerade
gehört
eine aussage aus der afc in sachsen
anhalt war die menschen möchten im
grunde eine koalition dieser beiden
konservativen parteien
das bespreche ich gleich mit ihr noch
mal aber eine sache müssen wir noch mal
kurz thematisieren es gibt beschwerden
das jetzt hier bei matthias fornoff bei
den möglichen koalitionen nicht darüber
gesprochen wird dass da beschwert sich
karl ofd mit der cdu 54 sitze hätte und
das ist auch anzuzeigen weil da sagt wir
als zdf sind der neutralität
verpflichtet und sollen deswegen alles
zeigen was möglich wäre so jetzt müssen
wir einfach feststellen
es würde man könnte das natürlich zeigen
abbilden aber so eine koalition ist ja
einfach ja im grunde ausgeschlossen von
daher könnte man sich die sendezeit auch
sparen
ja absolut also es gibt eine klare
aussage von der cdu es gibt eine klare
aussage von reiner haseloff ja er sagt
auf gar keinen fall zusammen mit der afd
es wirkt nicht passieren es wäre
harakiri
es wäre tatsächlich harakiri die cdu hat
gerade schon viel internen streit durch
leute wie hans georg maßen ehemals
verfassungsschutzpräsident und auch den
neuen vorsitzenden der werte union von
der man sich zwar abgrenzt die sich aber
an die union ja an dort die einen neuen
vorsitzenden eben hat max otte der
vergangene woche mit af generativen den
angeblich mittlerweile politisch
instrumentalisierten verfassungsschutz
in interviews aufgefallen ist und auch
in der vergangenheit schon aufgefallen
ist also würde jetzt reiner haseloff
sagen satte mehrheit mit der afg im
sachsen anhalter landtag
ich weiß nicht wie schnell armin laschet
auf dem weg nach sachsen anhalts wäre
und noch versuchen würde das zu
verhindern denn das wäre tatsächlich ein
riesen tabubruch den wert sehr viele
wähler nicht verzeihen würden nicole ich
danke dir für deine einschätzungen und
wünsche dir noch einen schönen wahlabend
nach berlin
und wir schalten rüber nach magdeburg zu
unserem studioleiter hat dort für
sachsen-anhalt andreas weise hallo
andreas du kannst nicht hören ja ich
kann hören hallo aus magdeburg
wundervoll also auch an dicht die frage
des arbeit ergebnis dieses abends ist ja
relativ
eindeutig war dass du dich überraschend
dass reiner haseloff so klar die
mehrheit auf seiner seite hat
die umfragen hatten ist ja schon ein
bisschen angedeutet wir hatten ja schon
sieben prozentpunkte 4 prozentpunkte
forschung das ist am ende so viel
geworden ist ich glaube da haben wir
viele wähler am ende doch noch mal
überlegt wo sie ihr kreuz machen
gelitten haben natürlich vor allem die
anderen parteien darunter nicht so sind
nicht so sehr die afd die hat ja kaum
verluste hinnehmen müssen 1,2
prozentpunkte nach den derzeitigen
hochrechnungen und auch wenn wir jetzt
noch abwarten müssen wie das ergebnis
der briefwähler aussieht es wird im
moment noch alles ausgezählt am ende
mussten die anderen parteien aus dem
spektrum der mitte und die linke
natürlich auch federn lassen
davon ist sehe ich denke ich mal sehr
sehr viel zur cdu gewandert weil es
immer hieß entweder ihr wählt die cdu
oder die afg wird stärkste partei und
das wollten dann viele hier im
bundesland sachsen-anhalt dann doch
nicht auf gar keinen fall
jetzt haben wir zwei parteien ganz klar
verloren wir darüber gesprochen spd und
die linken ich guck mal kurz die spd ihr
hat - 25 prozentpunkte verloren die
linke sogar minus 5,4 prozentpunkte gibt
es eine frage von dirk witte was ist mit
der fdp was sagen die analysen warum
diese partei gewählt wurde anstelle der
spd und der linken was ist an einer
einschätzung
die fdp war zehn jahre lang nicht im
landtag und eigentlich haben es die
liberalen im osten insgesamt relativ
schwer es ist nicht wirklich die
klientel hier aber die fdp hat im
wahlkampf relativ zeitig auch eine art
sammer gemäßigte corona kritik anklingen
lassen ihr slogan war ein land fährt
hoch und da ging es eben darum dass die
ganzen einschränkungen wie zum beispiel
dass man nicht in die restaurants dorf
und dass man viele andere sachen nicht
läuft das halt die afg auch für
überzogen sie hat es aber natürlich
nicht so radikal und nicht mit diesem
habitus herübergebracht wie die afd
und ich denke dass das genau die stimmen
sind von wählern die vielleicht auch von
anderen parteien weg oder von der afg
oder von der cdu weg gegangen sind und
dort bei der entschuldigung bei der fdp
dann angedockt haben jetzt habe ich
gerade auch den ministerpräsidenten von
sachsen anhalt gehört reiner haseloff
der wohl auch der nächste
ministerpräsident wird davon können wir
ausgehen
der hat im gespräch mit bettina
schausten gerade beklagt dass in den des
deutschen medien das hat er tatsächlich
so gesagt weil die meisten medienhäuser
im westen sein sagte er
nicht die themen besprochen werden die
die menschen im osten oder in seinem
bundesland in sachsen-anhalt bewegen was
sind das für themen und findest du diese
kritik nachvollziehbar du bist ja dort
im bundesland unterwegs und bisher auch
derjenige der von dort für uns berichtet
also ich würde mal sagen dass ich jetzt
für uns für unser landesstudio für das
zdf landesstudio sachsen anhalt hier in
magdeburg sein kann dass wir uns immer
sehr bemühen genau über die themen zu
berichten die die sachsen-anhalter
interessieren ist natürlich für ein
bundesweites medium wie unseres auch
immer eine sache wir müssen uns
natürlich gegen viele andere themen auch
durchsetzt und trotzdem finde ich dass
wir mit unseren themen relativ gut
durchkommen auch im zdf gesamtprogramm
und dann ist das auch immer finde ich
eine kritik ja es gibt ja nicht nur das
zdf es gibt auch noch viele andere
es gibt ja auch noch zum beispiel den
mdr hier in sachsen anhalt in diesem
ganzen mitteldeutschen gebiet der schon
sehr viel von diesen themen aufgreift ja
sie ständig mit diesen themen
beschäftigt es gibt die tageszeitung
also ich finde diese kritik ist auch ein
bisschen überzogen aus meiner
persönlichen sicht zumindest ist das ein
bisschen der versuchte anzudocken was
die afg ja auch immer sagt wir werden
nicht repräsentiert wir werden nicht
gesehen dass es zumindest so ein kleiner
haken ist natürlich ist es das natürlich
ist es dass es ist ja auch eine
absetzbewegung von berlin ja
ministerpräsident haseloff hat sich auch
über die bundesliste wahnsinnig
aufgeregt die hätte ihm stimmen gekostet
am ende ist es gar nicht so gewesen
natürlich ist das der versuch sich
darzustellen als als als eine art nicht
beachtete volksgruppe sozusagen
ja es ist ja so dass sich viele hier in
sachsen anhalt schon das hat ja haben
auch die umfragen gezeigt wir haben am
anfang der wahlsendungen über 60 prozent
fühlen sich als bürger zweiter klasse
fühlen sich nicht richtig repräsentiert
da muss man natürlich darüber nachdenken
woran liegt das aber vielleicht müssen
auch die bürger manchmal darüber
nachdenken warum ist es so was kann ich
dagegen tun
das ist etwas was ich persönlich
manchmal hier noch ein bisschen vermisst
nur ist es aber doch so dass zumindest
die statistiken sagen menschen aus
deutschland arbeiten mehr verdienen
weniger sind in den landesparlamenten in
den parteispitzen in der gerichtsbarkeit
nicht so vertreten das wird immer noch
westdeutsch dominiert ist das etwas was
ich vielleicht jetzt auch ändern muss
das war ja auch so ein bisschen der
ansatz der linken zu sagen wir brauchen
einfach mehr leute hier aus dem land die
uns repräsentieren definitiv da muss
sich etwas ändern und zwar schnell das
geht zwar wahrscheinlich nicht schnell
was müsste sich schnell was ändern wenn
man mal schaut die landesregierung hier
in sachsen anhalt da sind zwei minister
die aus ostdeutschland kommen der rest
hat den westdeutschen bag warnt wir
haben das an vielen anderen stellen im
land natürlich auch aber auf der anderen
seite ist es auch so dass sind oft leute
die sind dann teilweise schon vor 25 30
jahren aus dem westen in den osten
gekommen sind also auch schon sehr lange
hier kennen natürlich auch die sorgen
und nöte der leute hier das sind ja
nicht irgendwelche leute die ja
eingeflogen wurden irgendwann mal
ich glaube dass es letztendlich etwas zu
tun hat mit diesem gefühl da ist jemand
der mich versteht der hat die ddr
vielleicht noch miterlebt der hat da so
ein gewisses verständnis für manche
denkweise für eine andere handlungsweise
die dann an den tag gelegt wird
ich glaube das ist etwas was den leuten
fehlt da fühlen sie sich nicht wirklich
repräsentiert an vielen stellen und das
sollte sich definitiv ändern
ich glaube auch dass sich das ändern
wird weil ich glaube dass das
bewusstsein dafür schon da ist wir
werden sehen die landes die
sachsen-anhalter die politik die haben
es hier in der hand wenn die leiste
nächste landesregierung gegründet wird
das dann vielleicht da das verhältnis
zwischen denen mit einer ost biografie
in der west biografie vielleicht ein
anderes ist als wir es jetzt in der
aktuellen landesregierung sehen reiner
haseloff hat auch gerade im gesprächen
allee fand eine elefantenrunde gesagt
man muss bei der bundestagswahl
ostdeutsche spezifika beachten also hat
im endeffekt gesagt also im westdeutsch
westdeutschland wird der kanzler die
kanzlerin gewählt in ostdeutschland wird
er oder sie verhindert kann es
tatsächlich sein dass jetzt bei der
bundestagswahl das wahlergebnis wie wir
es jetzt haben ganz anders aussehen wird
in sachsen-anhalt
das kann durchaus sein es ist natürlich
der berühmte blick in die kristallkugel
ich glaube persönlich nicht dass das
ergebnis so anders aussehen wird als
jetzt ist auch noch ist noch über drei
monate zeit es kann noch sehr viel
passieren das kann auf der einen seite
ein wunderbarer sommer werden so ein
post corona sommer wo alle wieder ein
bisschen durchatmen wo das leben sich
wieder normalisiert und dann werden wir
sehen dann ist das wahlverhalten der
leute vielleicht ein anderes als es
vielleicht noch vor einem oder vor zwei
monaten gewesen wäre
ja und dann müssen wir natürlich auch
noch sehen bis jetzt haben wir ja vom
kandidaten laschet auch noch nicht so
wirklich viel gehört was er will wo er
mit deutschland als gesamtes land hin
will
da werden die leute hier in
ostdeutschland natürlich sehr genau
darauf gucken aber ich glaube auch armin
laschet weiß ganz genau dass er
natürlich sich auch in ostdeutschland
kümmern muss wir haben ja auch am selben
tag wie der bundestagswahl auch noch
wahrscheinlich von meinem in thüringen
ist das noch nicht ganz klar noch drei
andere landtagswahlen im osten nämlich
in mecklenburg in berlin und in
thüringen dann wahrscheinlich und da
muss man natürlich auch genau auf diese
geschichte eingehen also der osten wird
sicherlich davon bin ich überzeugt in
dieser bundestagswahl oder im wahlkampf
dazu nicht außer acht gelassen
ich habe jetzt hier ein paar kritische
anmerkungen im stream da geht es aber um
wahlbetrug da können wir gleich noch mal
darauf eingehen aber eine frage hier von
danny boyle oder besser eine
feststellung können wir auch gern mal
ganz kurz zeigen hier bei mir auf dem
bildschirm
hier ruft haseloff haseloff also falsch
geschrieben einfach zum sieger aus ohne
dass die wahl vorbei ist also die wahl
ist jetzt anderthalb stunden vorbei
lenny aber vielleicht kann man das noch
mal ganz kurz erklären diese jetzt dazu
kommen tatsächlich zu sagen die cdu hat
die wahl gewonnen
nun ja es gibt die entsprechenden
befragung es wird ja seit 18 uhr
ausgezählt die ergebnisse der schon
ausgezählten bezirken wandern natürlich
sofort in die sogenannten hochrechnung
mit hinein und die prognosen die dort
gestellt werden die sind ja jahrzehnten
sind die sehr genau und die halten sich
ziemlich eng sind ziemlich eng am
amtlichen endergebnis dann auch dran
deswegen das ist doch eine wirklich seit
jahrzehnten geübte praxis die immer gut
funktioniert hat und man hat ja auch
gesehen dass zum beispiel die umfragen
die ard und zdf gemacht
vor der wahl deutlich näher an dem dran
waren als die die andere medien gemacht
haben und das ist auf jeden fall ein
sehr verlässliches konstrukt und da kann
man wirklich davon ausgehen da wird
irgendwie nichts geschoben oder sonst
etwas warum auch genau das ist die frage
jetzt auch nach wahlbetrug das lese ich
immer wieder
vielleicht kannst du danach ein paar
sätze zu sagen also wie wird das quasi
gala und wahlbetrug hat erich von
wahlbetrug habe ich hier nichts wenn wir
hier nichts mitbekommen warum wahlbetrug
das ist natürlich der versuch von vielen
wieder ein relativ ähnlich wie
vielleicht die republikaner das in den
usa gemacht haben einfach so zu tun
wahlbetrug keine beweise dafür gar
nichts aber es wird von wahlbetrug
gesprochen wenn es beweise gibt zum
wahlbetrug dann musste ihnen natürlich
nachgegangen werden wenn es den wirklich
geben sollte ja natürlich ist hier mal
in sachsen anhalt ein fall bei einer
stadtrats war das dann bei der briefwahl
betrogen wurde das ist aber aufgeflogen
das ist aufgeflogen
die leute sind dann auch entsprechend
dann mussten dann die konsequenzen
daraus ziehen das war ein einziger fall
und das ist schon ein paar jahre her
also von wahlbetrug haben wir hier bis
jetzt überhaupt nichts gehört und ich
glaube auch nicht dass es hier
wahlbetrug gibt ganz ehrlich und ich
glaube aber wir können unseren
zuschauerinnen und zuschauern sagen
werden dass wahlbetrug geben würde und
wir würden davon mitbekommt wäre dann
wäre die ersten und ich glaube andreas
auch die sich auf diese geschichte
stürzen würden absolut definitiv aber
wie gesagt das ist das ist etwas was ich
wirklich schon jetzt seit geraumer zeit
beobachtet wird gesprochen dass die
briefwahl anfällig für wahlbetrug wäre
da kommt dieses negativ was aus den usa
kommt von den letzten
präsidentschaftswahlen das wird einfach
hier herein getragen da wird von
wahlbetrug gesprochen ohne beweise
vorzulegen
und da bin ich gespannt wenn die beweise
vorgelegt werden und sie glaubwürdig
sind okay dann gehen wir demnach aber
ohne beweise einfach mal von wahlbetrug
zu reden das halte ich für gefährlich
und demokratie zu ersetzen
andreas ich bedanke mich für seine zeit
und seine einschätzungen heute abend und
wünschen noch einen schönen abend in
magdeburg und wir sind dann gespannt was
die endgültigen ergebnisse die dann
wahrscheinlich im laufe des abends
bekanntgegeben werden tatsächlich sagen
grund hat kann sich noch ein bisschen
ziehen bis in die nacht hinein
wir schauen dann so kurze bestehe hier
von morgen er sagt ich sei sehr
unprofessionell denn ich hätte den
kommentator respektlos behandelt und auf
die rechtschreibung hingewiesen
leute das muss ich machen wenn da der
name falsch geschrieben wird und wir
zeigen dass hier an auf dem bildschirm
muss ich kurz sagen der name ist falsch
geschrieben dann wird ihr irgendwie euch
das merken kann so sehr unsympathisch
ein paar und partei statt sich einfach
mal so stehen lieber kannst du so finden
die du möchtest es gab eine frage liebe
kollegen in der regie das würde ich ganz
gerne mal zeigen bevor wir gleich zu
unseren drei kandidatinnen schalten die
sich ja den abend damit vertrieben haben
zu gucken ob sie den nächsten
landtagsabgeordnete werden weil ein user
wollte sehr vehement wissen wie denn die
verschiedenen parteien nach alten
gewählt wurden und das können wir uns
tatsächlich angucken auf unserer
homepage zdf heute die haben wir hier
immer hingelegt und dort sehen wir die
verschiedenen wahl strukturen also
wählte die cdu nach alter da können wir
sehen ganz klar 44 prozent der cdu
wählerinnen und wähler waren über 60 der
rest verteilt sich 34 prozent waren
zwischen 45 und 59 27 prozent zwischen
30 und 44 und nur 17 prozent waren unter
30 eine slide weiter können wir sehen
wen wer wettet die afg auch wieder nach
alter da verteilt sich das ist ganz
interessant wäre die cdu hier sondern
klare leiter hat ist die afg
einigermaßen gleichmäßig verteilt 18
prozent waren über 60 27 prozent waren
zwischen 45 und 59 30 prozent ist ein
bisschen die mehrheit waren zwischen 30
und 44 und 20 prozent unter 30 alles
muss man sagen quelle forschungsgruppe
wahlen die für uns vor den wahllokalen
gestanden haben um das ganze zu
evaluieren dann haben wir hier die linke
auch da eigentlich eine gleichmäßige
verteilung zehn prozent sind unter 30 9
prozent zwischen 30 und 44 10 prozent
zwischen 45 und 59 und 14 prozent über
60 und so geht das für jede partei noch
mal kurz die spd angeguckt so sieht das
auch bei denen aus sieben prozent oder
30 60 zwischen 30 und 44 6 prozent
zwischen 45 und 49 11 prozent über 60
also da haben wir jede partei könnt ihr
mal gucken bei uns zdf heute.de oder in
der app die hoffentlich schon ganz
geladen habt weil da gibt es jetzt ganz
ganz viele zahlen daten und fakten hier
in der ersten zeit da könnt ihr euch
das anschauen was euch interessieren
könnte so und mich interessiert jetzt
wie das aussieht mit unseren drei
kandidatinnen die um den einzug in den
landtag gewandt haben wir haben vorhin
schon mal gesprochen
mit antje schulze in halle mit
constantin pott in magdeburg und mit tim
tessmann von der cdu verschiedene
parteien und verschiedene wahlkreise und
jetzt schalten wir als erstes mal zu
constantin pott 23 schulz wird auch
nicht okay da habt ihr weitere
reihenfolge wieder umgeworfen liebe
kollegen ich hatte mir herrn port
aufgeschrieben dann sagen wir gehen wir
zuerst zu frau schulze zuschauer schulz
1 schulz 1 30 juristin wir gucken muss
noch mal kurz ihren steckbrief an antje
schulz 30 jahre alt vorsitzende der
grünen im stadtverband halle die
juristin promoviert zurzeit an der uni
halle ihre schwerpunkte in wissenschaft
und politik tierschutzrecht und
demokratie bei der wahl heute tritt sie
als direktkandidatin in halle an und
steht auf platz 11 der landesliste so
platz auf der landesliste die grünen
haben zwar etwas zugelegt frau schulz
aber nicht so viel wie gedacht wissen
sie schon wie es aussieht also gerade
ist immer noch alles ein bisschen blick
in die glaskugel meiner meinung nach das
erste ergebnis was jetzt solide uns auf
6,5 gebracht hat also 65 prozent das ist
jetzt einfach meine marke die es besser
als das ergebnis vor fünf jahren das ist
schon mal einmal zum tief durchatmen und
entspannt sein und jetzt warten wir
einfach den abend ab und freuen uns auf
jeden kommen pro zent punkt den wir im
lauf des abends eigentlich noch weiter
nach oben wandern wie viel müsste denn
drin sein damit sie über die landesliste
reinrutschen
ganz ehrlich mit solchen mit solchen
zahlenspielen beschäftige ich mich gar
nicht also für mich zählt jetzt
irgendwas
das ergebnis ich habe das jetzt nicht
alles durch durch die rechner die man
digital abrufen kann durch gezählt
sondern einfach nur je mehr
prozentpunkte desto mehr sitze werden
wir auch haben das ist gut weil jeder
einzelne sind denen wir grünen mehr
abgreifen im landtag wird bessere
klimapolitik in den nächsten fünf jahren
haben heißen und auch mehr demokratische
teilhabe und eine klare kante gegen
rechts und das ist eigentlich gerade das
was so bei mir sind das heißt im laufe
des abends kommt ein anruf und dann
heißt es entweder ja und hier du bist
drin oder soria hat nicht gereicht ja so
ungefähr genau also gerade bin ich
gerade bin ich ganz zufrieden mit dem
ergebnis klar wir hätten uns mehr
erhofft als ich sage mal erstes
zwischenergebnis
aber der abend ist noch lang und solange
fiebern wir mit wie gesagt um jeden
prozentpunkt
hätten sie denn gedacht dass die cdu um
reiner haseloff so stark abschneidet es
ist schwer zu sagen ob er jetzt wirklich
so gut abgeschnitten hat weil das haben
sie ja auch schon dargestellt in ihrer
sendung
viele dinge sind einfach noch nicht
ausgezählt das heißt die prozente können
sich noch stark verschieben und
zumindest so was ich mitbekommen habe
auf der straße im gespräch mit den
wählerinnen und wählern
viele junge menschen haben die briefwahl
gewählt für sich viele junge menschen
die die briefwahl gewählt haben haben
mir signalisiert und auch meinen
freundinnen und freunden auf der straße
dass sie die grüne gewählt haben dass
sie im linken spektrum gewählt haben und
gerade nicht die cdu oder die afd
und von daher bin ich mir noch sicher
dass sich das ergebnis der cdu so wie es
jetzt gerade durch streit dass es das
noch nicht gewesen ist und dass es sich
noch abflachen wird
gut dann schauen wir mal was im laufe
des abends passiert ob sie ihn anrufe
kriegen werden wir dann nicht mehr live
miterleben weil es da stellt sich noch
ein bisschen dauern kann
trotzdem vielen dank dass sie dabei
waren und uns ein bisschen haben
teilhaben lassen und wir schalten weiter
zu dem test man von der cdu
verwaltungsfachangestellter und hier ist
ein steckbrief
tim tessmann 31 jahre alt
landtagskandidat der cdu
der gelernte sozialpädagoge und
verwaltungsfachangestellte studiert
aktuell digitalisierung und
sozialstruktur wandel seit 2009 10 sitzt
er im sozialausschuss des stadtrats von
haldensleben
dort tritt er als direktkandidat an sein
listenplatz 25
listenplatz 25 jahre tessmann wissen sie
schon ob das reicht na ja wie gesagt ich
bin ja noch direktkandidat und
mittlerweile liege ich dort vorne mit
knapp 38 prozent was ich gesehen habe
und dann brauche ich ja den listenplatz
oder beziehungsweise titel ist für mich
nicht das heißt sie machen sich gute
hoffnungen dass sie den direkt direkten
wahlkreis 30 holen so wie zur zeit der
aktuelle stand aussieht mir wurde gerade
gesagt auf ihrer homepage kann man was
sehen ist das so dass man da schon mal
gucken kann wie es aussehen ich bin bei
uns auch der landkreis heute kann man
auf jeden fall was nicht und da war ich
eben ich hab noch mal geguckt bei 38
prozent
wie wo ist dann wo ist denn ihre
konkurrenz scheint die gala ab ich
glaube zweitplatzierte dass die afg und
sei damit jetzt nicht geguckt muss ich
sagen okay
sie sitzt ein bisschen verhalten freuen
sie sich gar nicht denn dort aber ist es
ja noch nicht alles ausgezeichnet
ausgezählt deswegen passt man den ball
flach halten und gucken was der an und
bringt ich bin da immer kein freund von
bevor abgeführten wird da schon zu
jubeln und ich habe auch schon ganz
viele nachrichten gekriegt aber habe das
handy erst mal weit weg gelegt
also was die nachrichten und whatsapp
angeht und gucke was da noch passiert so
viel können mal ganz kurz gucken hätte
erst mal ich habe mir hier mal aufgelegt
die wahlergebnisse vom landeswahlleiter
für ihren wahlkreis auf mein tablet hier
neben mir dass es der wahlkreis 07
halbes leben und dort steht tatsächlich
tessmann tim
1752 stimmen für sie das entspricht 39,1
prozent punkte das ist der zwischenstand
19 uhr 11 und hinter ihnen kommt von der
af ddr markus kottmann der hat 1151
stimmen bis jetzt 25,7 das sieht nach
einem ganz ordentlichen vorsprung aus
das heißt aber sie möchten tatsächlich
erst das bierchen aufmachen oder die
korken knallen lassen wenn die landes
landesverwaltung sagt okay jetzt ist es
amtlich sie haben gewonnen also wieder
das auf das bier habe ich nur verzichtet
werden das interview machen wollten
und da kann ich dann gleich mal einen
schon mal nehmen aber dann gucken wir
was noch dabei herauskommt noch nicht
wissen sie dann schon wie es weitergehen
würde also wenn sie jetzt und auch
festabends erfahren sie sind es geworden
was passiert dann
ja also letzte woche hatte ich mit dem
landtagsabgeordneten telefoniert und er
meinte im falle der wahl wäre morgen
gleich die erste sitzung von unserer
fraktion bzw gewählten mitgliedern
natürlich die annahme des mandats steht
aus und beim alten arbeitgeber muss ich
mich natürlich auch noch verabschieden
und übergabe machen wenn es so kommt da
steht dann stünden dann große
veränderungen an hätte erstmal an vielen
dank da sind wir gespannt was passiert
und ich danke ihnen dass sie heute abend
zeit für uns haben so und als letzter
hatten wir ja von der fdp
konstantin ports 23 für den wahlkreis 38
platz 7 der landesliste und hier ist ein
steckbrief constantin pott 23 jahre alt
spitzenkandidat der jungen liberalen in
sachsen anhalt
dort studiert politik und
wirtschaftswissenschaften seine
politischen themen bildung jugend
digitalisierung
er ist der jüngste direktkandidat in
halle seine partei wählte ihn auf platz
7 der landesliste so herb ort hören sie
mich sieht ein bisschen abenteuerlich
gerade haus ja ich kann sie mir dann
können sie mich hören ich kann sich auch
er hat wundervoll so also wir haben
gesehen die fdp hat 6,8 prozent das ist
zumindest unsere hochrechnung 1924
zufrieden damit
ja auf jeden fall nicht mehr bei
demokraten in sachsen anhalt müssen wir
uns nicht verstecken wir haben in einem
zug den wiedereinzug in den landtag nach
vielen jahren abgeschafft und das auch
ohne zu zittern ohne irgendwie noch
einen langen abend zu haben oder wie
sich erfolg bei und sagte nein halb und
ich glaube da können wir auf jeden fall
feiern
und wie sieht es bei ihnen persönlich
aus wird es reichen über ihren anschluss
daran zu kommen
das wird der lange an das heißt sie sind
der sie werden quasi derjenige der
tatsächlich ist nicht mehr schafft genau
aber müssen natürlich schauen
die cdu hat ein sehr starkes ergebnis
sie mit gucken vielleicht holen die sehr
viele wahlkreise dann kann es natürlich
durch ausgleichsmandate auch noch
reichen das heißt langer abend wird das
wir müssen gucken die haben den brief
weder abgestimmten ich bleibe da
optimistisch auch wenn es natürlich ein
langer abend mit wenig schlaf
das heißt im endeffekt kann es
tatsächlich an ein paar dutzend stimmen
liegen ob sie auch morgen dann zur
ersten fraktionssitzung antreten oder
nicht ja genau das kann
wir haben nirgends bringen werden aber
wie gesagt wir müssen abwarten ich
bleibe optimistisch und wir können auch
noch glaube ich werden noch ein bisschen
luft nach oben vor allem was die bürger
angehe und da war hat mir jetzt einfach
ab und schauen wir decken so ein
bisschen sind ziemlich entspannt ist es
tatsächlich so oder geht ihnen doch so
ein bisschen im buch ich glaube ich war
vor der ersten hochrechnung bedeuten
oder von ihrer prognose bedeuten
angespanntheit spielen einfach
froh dass wir es geschafft haben mit
einem starken ergebnis wenn wir wieder
anzuziehen
da bin ich jetzt auch nicht so dass das
sich da nur auf mich zentriert minder
wichtig ist fatal geschafft haben ein
team geschafft haben wieder in den
landtag einzuziehen
und ich hoffe natürlich dass für mich
klappt aber dann bin ich entspannt weil
ich mir ganz sicher sein kann dass auch
wenn ich nicht dabei bin die fraktion
eine ganz zu bearbeiten
glauben sie denn dass es zu einer
koalition unter beteiligung der fdp
kommen könnte kommen kann kann es dazu
ob jeden fall haben im wahlkampf ja auch
immer ganz klar gesagt dass wir bereit
sind für verantwortung dass mir dafür
zur verfügung stehen wir müssen aber
glaube ich da abwarten wie an und wird
nämlich die einzelnen sitze aussehen die
mir genau die mehrheitsverhältnisse sind
wir haben natürlich jetzt grobes bringt
schon mal da sieht es erst mal ganz gut
aus dass das sie vielleicht auch in eine
regierungsbeteiligung gibt aber wir
müssen natürlich auch die gespräche
abwarten was können wir ein team durch
bringen was können wir einen themen in
den koalitionsverhandlungen am ende
einbringen und gucken wir uns
durchsetzen und wir werden genau wie wir
das auf bundesebene aufgemacht haben
nicht unsere wahlversprechen verraten
sondern wir wollen dann eben auch dass
wir unsere wichtigen weiter sprechen die
wienerinnen und mir auch wirklich
durchsetzen können ich habe gerade noch
mal hier aufgerufen mögliche koalitionen
bei uns auf der seite
da gäbe es die möglichkeit cdu spd und
fdp würden auf die gleiche anzahl von
sitzen kommen wie cdu spd und grünen er
mich 46 dh im endeffekt müssen sie die
grünen ausstechen
ja gut da hängt es natürlich auch ein
bisschen an den anderen parteien nicht
nur wünschen würden ich glaube ich nicht
dass wir eine stabile regierungen
sachsen anhalt ich würde mir natürlich
wünschen dass unter beteiligung der mit
wenn wir unser team durch gewirkt
bekommen da müssen wir einfach abwarten
aber ich bleibe da erst einmal
optimistisch statt dass eine deutsche co
liegt nach einem nein wäre da auch sehr
optimistisch wir freie demokraten dort
unsere inhalte mit einbringen können und
ein ungefähr auf nebenbei der
koalitionsvertrag eine liberale
handschrift trug dann sind wir gespannt
die das in sachsen-anhalt ausgeht vielen
dank herr pott und ja mal schauen
ob sie es noch schaffen auf jeden fall
ein sehr spannender abend für sie ja auf
jeden fall auf jeden berg und auch im
namen noch danke sehr
so wir würden ganz gerne noch sprechen
gleich mit matthias fornoff der ganz
frische zahlen für uns haben wird gegen
kurz vor 8 und der tina chancen in
unserem wahlstudio
bis dahin sind es noch ein paar minuten
arbeit zum glück steht mir nicole
diekmann nochmal zur verfügung in berlin
denn ich höre dass die leitung steht
nicole ist noch da sehr schön weil
comeback ich schaue gerade noch mal was
wir so anfragen haben es wird langsam
eine schöne traditionen du mich immer
verabschieden dürfen
ich bleib einfach nur zu immer hier
sitzen dann ist ja gut dass ich mich
zurück zwischendurch war es hoffentlich
kurz was trinken
ich habe hier eine frage von johanna die
meinte meinen sie tatsächlich die cdu
hat viele neue händler für sich gewonnen
oder sind dass er leute die verhindern
wollten dass die afg stärkste kraft wird
das ist immer schwierig so zu sagen es
ist jetzt sehr spezifische fragen
das ist also was ich einen interessanten
aspekt heute abend finde ist dass die
zahl der protestwähler innen in sachsen
anhalt ganz offensichtlich auch
geschrumpft ist da wird tatsächlich aus
überzeugung gewählt protest wählerinnen
erkennt man zum beispiel daran dass man
fragt leute die die gewählt haben
hätten sie gerne die art die auch in der
regierung und protest leute die aus
protest gewählt haben sagen dann die
zwar gewählt aber keine wollen aber
keine regierungsbeteiligung dieser
partei sondern sollten einfach den
anderen denkzettel verpassen
das hat sich heute abend komplett
geändert da kursieren werte von 94
prozent die sagen ja die sollen auch
schön an die regierung das heißt da hat
man tatsächlich aus überzeugung eine
partei gewählt ich sage das nochmal die
vom landesverfassungsschutz beobachtet
wird in sachsen-anhalt
das wurde die vor fünf jahren noch nicht
das hat an der prozentzahl den
prozentpunkten ziemlich wenig geändert
die leute wussten wen sie da heute
wählen und sie haben sie relativ viele
haben sie gewählt
da hatte ich gerade in der passende
frage zu auf facebook gesehen die finde
ich es auf anhieb nicht wieder aber ich
habe sie mir zum glück gemerkt die
gingen in die richtung was ist denn
jetzt eigentlich so schlimm daran vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet zu werden
sollen die doch ja gut das kann man so
sehen also der verfassungsschutz ist
dazu da im auge zu behalten wer könnte
eine gefahr werden für unsere
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
das ist die basis unseres staates
unseres miteinanders ja unserer
demokratie und eine partei die
beobachtet wird die ist schon in dem
fall über den prüfstand hinaus da wurden
also lange zeit offen einsehbaren
quellen ausgewertet wie zum beispiel
reden postings besonders wichtig bei der
fdp war da sehr aktiv sind in den
sozialen medien interviews
zeitungsinterviews fernsehinterviews und
so weiter und in sachsen-anhalt ist der
verfassungsschutz danach die sub
prüfphase zu der überzeugung gelangt ja
da könnte tatsächlich was dran sein
wir beobachten diese partei jetzt und
setzen auch nachrichtendienstliche
mittel ein
das äußerste mittel sind dann v-leute
telefonüberwachung e-mail-überwachung
das ist theoretisch möglich nach
richterlichen beschlüssen da weiter in
die tiefe zu gehen und eventuell am ende
zu dem schluss zu kommen sie sind
gesichert in dem fall
rechtsextremistisch also nochmal wer vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird der
ist zumindest schon mal in den verdacht
geraten gegen die freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung zu verstoßen
das ist nicht nichts
ich finde das interessant wenn man sieht
noch mal ein paar zahlen und daten hier
anguckt die die forschungsgruppe wahlen
für uns erhoben hat eine grafik die
können wir gerne noch mal hier auf
unserer monitor neben mir zeigen dann
muss die regie noch mal kurz umschalten
genau eine schöne fahrt aufs gerät hier
und da sieht man dann
eine umfrage ministerpräsident reiner
haseloff macht seine sache eher gut und
da sagten oder eher schlecht untersagten
wir gesehen es hier
81 prozent der befragten sagten er macht
sehr gut und 13 prozent sagten er macht
sie eher schlecht und wenn man sich
anguckt wie das sich auf die parteien
verteilt dann sagen 98 prozent der cdu
wähler ja er macht er gut und sogar 66
prozent der afg weder auch der rest der
wähler linke spd grüne sind mit reiner
haseloff er zufrieden ich würde sagen
hier sogar überwiegend zufrieden 77
prozent bei den linken 87 prozent bei
der spd 76 prozent bei der grünen nicole
das ist ja doch eher ungewöhnlich oder
dass ein landesvater wie es immer so
schön heißt so sehr überzeugt dass
selbst die politische konkurrenz sagt
die weder von ihnen ja er macht seine
sache gut was ist denn so wird zu sagen
sein geheimnis ja was ist sein geheimnis
also was natürlich jetzt gerade in
dieser sehr polarisierten zeit ein
wichtiges erkennungsmerkmal würde ich
mal nennen von reiner haseloff ist und
er vor allem im osten eben auch eine
rolle spielt ist die klare abgrenzung
zur afd da haben ja andere aus seiner
partei schon gewackelt erinnern uns er
hat deswegen auch sein innenminister
stahlknecht seinerzeit tja verabschiedet
sagen wir es mal so
das ist nicht allen in der cdu so klar
wie haseloff dass diese brandmauer ich
sage es jetzt auch noch mal das ist ja
mittlerweile ein sehr viel zitierter
begriff auch in vergangenen wochen
gewesen dass diese brandmauer bestehen
mussten zur afg dass man sich ganz klar
abgrenzt in seinem land und das wird
also von fd wählern wird es
wahrscheinlich nicht sehr goutiert aber
das ist sicherlich auch vor allem für
wähler innen der der linken parteien
aber natürlich auch der fdp die ja sehr
auf die nase gefallen ist mal in
thüringen sachen afd
das ist sicherlich ein wichtiger punkt
der da der damit spielt und haseloff hat
sich in den vergangenen wochen auch
immer mal wieder kritisch zu wort
gemeldet was die korona maßnahmen angeht
in den vergangenen monaten ja das hat er
sicherlich auch mit reingespielt da
waren ja auch nicht alle mit
einverstanden
ich habe hier nochmals einen kommentar
hier weil es tatsächlich endlich in den
kommentaren bei uns nur um pro oder
kontra fd geht der für dich ganz
interessantes den ich von dir gerne mal
eingeschätzt haben würde
falls du dich ja mit der afg schon sehr
beschäftigt mal gern auf meinen rechner
schalten
denn bernd verschueren schreibt ihr ich
finde es interessant wie immer alle
gegen die afg wettern obwohl jede partei
dreck am stecken hat sie gefälschte
doktorarbeiten masten skandale und so
weiter also keine partei meint er kann
sich frei sprechen von schuld überall
ist dreck am stecken und trotzdem
schauen alle nur auf die afd frage
nicole ist das so richtig und frage b
kann man das auch ja ist es tatsächlich
so dass das alle parteien irgendwo dreck
am stecken haben und bis dahin bayers
gibt die man dass man also eine eine
ungleich gewichtung in der darstellung
naja ich finde die fragestellung sprache
ich schon ganz interessant denn wir
wetter nicht sondern wie berichten wir
machen unseren job ja also wir berichten
von parteitagen wir berichten über
aktuelle entwicklungen blick auf die
aktuell hoch stehenden themen
das ist das eine die man wettert und zum
zweiten kann ich mich nicht erinnern
dass hier nicht über die maßen skandale
bei cdu und csu berichtet hätten dass
sie nicht über die nachmeldungen der
grünen annalena baerbock zb jetzt
berichtet hätten was ihr weihnachtsgeld
angehen dass in den vergangenen tagen
vor allen dingen landauf landab in den
medien über den er hat es heute
dementiert deswegen muss man seinen
vermeintlichen neuen masten skandal von
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn cdu
berichtet hätten also das halte ich für
eine sehr einseitige wahrnehmung grund
was ich auch sagen muss ist alles was
ich gerade genannt habe und diese liste
ließe sich fortsetzen auch die anderen
parteien da läuft das auch nicht immer
rund auch da passieren dinge die ich
passieren dürfen gar keine frage das
aber
die nähe zum rechtsextremismus da ist
bei der afg das lässt sich ja
mittlerweile nicht mehr abstreiten und
dass wir darüber berichten
also wie gesagt das ist unsere aufgabe
nicole dann danke ich dir ich guck doch
mal kurz ja so dass ich finde ich
ziemlich ab bei uns im chat für dieses
thema polarisiert wirklich ja ja aber
das ist das thema paradies punkt
polarisiert wollte ich sagen war schon
viel gesprochen heute hier gibt es aber
auch ein kommentar von heidi gerade
massen affäre ist das eine
rechtsextremismus ist das andere also
tatsächlich ist die frage ob man auch
miteinander vergleichen kann
und darunter schreibt klar träume alle
hauen auf die afg weil sie eine gefahr
für die demokratie ist also das sind
auch hier ganz klare statements pro und
contra ist dass im endeffekt aber auch
was der afg wieder nutzt dass sie so
stark polarisiert das ist immer die
große frage aber gut wir haben jetzt
natürlich ein ergebnis in sachsen-anhalt
das nicht großartig sich unterscheidet
von dem vor fünf jahren also da kann man
jetzt nicht vom einbruch reden und wir
das machen wir ja auch transparent auch
wir in den redaktionen fragen uns ja
auch immer wieder warum darüber
berichten wir darüber berichten wir
nicht machen wir uns das gilt für alle
parteien also springen wir über staffel
die uns hingehalten werden weil jede
partei natürlich ein interesse daran hat
ford zu kommen in den medien
das tun wir natürlich auch bei der afg
aber also die berichten durchgängig über
die afg und in den bundesweiten umfragen
dümpelt die partei sagen sie auch selber
seit monaten vor sich hin also ich
glaube nicht dass man diesen komplett
dass diese kausalkette so kurz ist wie
man das manchmal darstellen darzustellen
versucht von der anderen politischen
seite wo man dann sagt ihr habt die erst
so groß gemacht wie sie sind und jetzt
sind sie euren wegen auch so groß also
ich glaube so einfach ist es nicht
und das war auch so unsere frage sein
also unsere
erstattungen darf sich ja nicht daran
orientieren wählten wir einen gefallen
und dämlich ja das wird uns noch mal
wieder vorgeworfen aber tatsächlich ist
es das was wir tun
nicole vielen dank für deine
einschätzungen jetzt aber wirklich
schluss war jetzt haben wir nicht mehr
viel vor und der abend ist falsch etwas
zu trinken holen denn jetzt schalten wir
nach magdeburg zu matthias fornoff der
die aktuellsten hochrechnungen für uns
hat wie mir gesagt wurde hallo herr
vorne auch wie sieht's aus
die informationen trifft zu wir haben
neue hochrechnung
das ist ja immer auch ganz schön wenn
die fakten grundlage stimmt auf der man
diskutiert und noch wird ja ausgezählt
nämlich alles ausgezählt die briefwahl
zum beispiel noch nicht kleinere
veränderungen kann es also noch geben
und wir schauen mal auf die neue
hochrechnung
demnach kommt die cdu auf 36 prozent und
gewinnt sehr deutlich dazu gegenüber dem
wahlergebnis von 2016 die afg 22,9 mit
leichten verlusten
die linke 10,7 mit deutlichen verlusten
die spd 8 prozent also ein stelle ich
auch mit klaren verlusten die grünen 5,9
prozent leichte zugewinne und die fdp
6,8 prozent plus 1,9 punkte kommt damit
nach zehn jahren wieder in den landtag
von magdeburg die freien wähler mit 3,1
prozent haben die fünf prozent hürde
verfehlung jetzt gucken wir uns mal an
was das fürs regieren in magdeburg heißt
das ist die magische senkrechte linie 42
sitze braucht man für die absolute
mehrheit wir sehen die jetzt amtierende
kenia koalition aus cdu spd und grünen
die kommt auf 46 ist also drüber das
reicht es würde auch reichen wenn man
sozusagen die fdp reihen nimmt und die
grüne raus die sogenannte deutschland
redaktion ebenfalls 46 sitze jamaika cdu
grüne fdp 45 sitze auch drüber und die
muss man sagen ehemals große koalition
cdu spd die käme auf 40 sitze
da fehlen zwei für die absolute mehrheit
so weit was die zeiten betrifft dann
gibt es jetzt natürlich die frage was
mit der briefwahl ist wissen sie
ungefähr wie groß die gruppe der
briefwählerinnen gewesen ist oder sein
könnte und wie sich das aufs
wahlergebnis dann auswirkt ja wir wissen
dass die
anzahl der briefwähler sich so ungefähr
verdoppelt hat allerdings auf niedrigem
niveau
in sachsen anhalt haben sozusagen
traditionell weniger leute briefwahl
gemacht als zb in baden württemberg da
lag der anteil im märz bei etwa 50
prozent briefwahl so viele sind es hier
nicht das wird noch ausgezählt
das ist für die forschungsgruppe wahlen
und für alle demoskopen ein relativ
schwieriges spiel wenn man noch nicht
weiß wie die zahlen sind bei der wahl
der briefwahl muss man ja annahmen
treffen wie brief wähler und wählerinnen
sie sich verhalten haben im vergleich zu
denen die im wahllokal gewählt werden
man rechnete aber nicht von riesig
großen abweichungen
heißt das jetzt also quasi an diesen
sitz verteidigen wie wir sie jetzt haben
40 dann großartig nichts mehr ändern
das heißt es da wird sich großartig
nichts mehr ändern ist kann auch noch
sein was die sitze betrifft 83 sitze
sind es ja mindestens dass die cdu noch
überhangmandate holt und die anderen
parteien ausgleichsmandate bekommt das
ändert aber nichts am kräfteverhältnis
nur an den zahlen
matthias waren auf vielen dank für die
aktuellen zahlen und dann sind wir
gespannt wie das endergebnis aussehen
wird und jetzt gehen wir weiter zu
bettina schausten die den wahlabend für
uns im zdf moderiert und begleitet hat
und ich bin gespannt frauchen wie sie
diese entwicklungen jetzt einschätzen
das ist ja doch für reiner haseloff ein
ziemlich gutes zeugnis haben sie das so
in dieser deutlichkeit kommen sehen ich
glaube die deutlichkeit war in der tat
für alle überraschend allerdings muss
man tatsächlich sagen wir haben es ein
bisschen kommen sehen denn die
forschungsgruppe wahlen hatte schon in
der vergangenen woche jahr die cdu vorn
gesehen und zwar deutlicher von gesehen
als andere
und dann gab es ja am vergangenen
donnerstag auch noch mal so ein
stimmungs punkt wo die stimmung
abgefragt worden war und da sah die
forschungsgruppe die cdu schon bei 30
mit sieben prozentpunkten abstand zur
afg also da konnte man sich eben schon
darauf einstellen